Morgen geht's. Guten Morgen Tim.
Das machst du sowieso die ganze Zeit.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer einhundertfünfundachtzig direkt vom Fußballplatz des netzpolitischen Geschehens.
Hast du gestern Fußball geguckt.
Ich gucke jeden Tag Fußball.
Was Fair hat gestern gespielt? Deutschland gegen Polen, ne? Und wie war das.
Deutschland. Deutschland gegen Polen, ne? Mhm. Wie war das? Ein knackiges, rassiges null zu null.
Null zu null.
So läuft das. Wird gekämpft und geschwitzt und gelaufen.
Ja, cool, sehr schön. War bestimmt spannend, Anne, anderthalb Stunden da äh Schlandrufe äh und am Ende nix gewesen.
Ja alles alles für die Katz sozusagen. Na ja, also ein Punkt ist ein Punkt, ne? So ist ja auch nie. Tja.
England hat gewonnen.
Ja, die müssen sich ja jetzt auch dran gewöhnen, sozusagen innerhalb des Landes ihre äh Kämpfe auszufechten, jetzt wo sie sich vom Kontinent abkoppeln wollen.
Ah, das ist ein Thema, was ich äh beschäftigt, ne.
Oh ja, natürlich.
Du möchtest nicht, dass dass wir die endlich rivellos sind.
Nee, nee, das ist auf keinen Fall, also das wäre ich glaube, das wäre äh nicht nur für die Briten echt ein richtig großes, richtiges Problem, sondern halt auch für uns und ähm
Allerdings ich äh bin mittlerweile latent, pessimistisch, was diese Geschichte betrifft. Mhm. Ja.
Aber lass uns nicht über äh Pullen und auch nicht über äh England reden. Auch nicht über Wales. Lass uns über die Schweiz reden, die Nuss.
Über die Schweiz, ja, das ist doch äh nee, das ist doch sehr viel spannender, da herrscht doch noch Sinn und Verstand in diesem Lande. Da äh.
Meinst du, ja?
Oder? Fragen wir mal Kiese.
Hey Kira.
Guten Morgen, morgen Tim. Das, das mit dem Verstand, das lasse ich mal so stehen.
Ja
Sich noch weisen.
Ich vermute mal, du verfolgst die Europameisterschaft, äh, der Herren nicht so.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht so mein bevorzugtes Them.
Ja, macht nichts, ich äh schaue da die Spiele für dich auch noch mit.
Ja, sehr gerne, danke.
Du äh beteiligst sich die Schweiz eigentlich an diesem Fußballturnier oder ist die neutral geblieben.
Mannheim, die ist da auch mit dabei und ja, weiß gar nicht wie erfolgreich, aber ich denke, ich glaube, gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ja, na ja gut, dass äh ja geht so.
Was da mit deinen Fußballern da hier äh über Fußball reden? Du bist doch jetzt auch immer bei diesem Fußballpodcast oder nicht.
Ja von Zeit zu Zeit.
Okay.
Möchtest das Thema jetzt hier nicht so haben? Ich äh auch immer.
Können auch über Fußball, also nein nein, sagen sie. Du, du kannst auch über Fußball reden.
Ich sehe schon, ich stehe hier äh fast im Abseits. Lass uns über die Schweiz.
Kira ähm.
Ja
Machen wir doch hier mal Anpfiff. Ähm,
Wir hatten das letzte Mal vor zwei Jahren tatsächlich äh das Vergnügen, etwas mehr als zwei Ja.
So lange her.
Ja
So lange ist das schon her, es war die Ausgabe Nummer hundertzwei und da hast du uns auch mal so einen ersten Zustandsbeschreibung der digitalen Gesellschaft, Schweiz geliefert
gibt's die Organisation noch und was ist seitdem passiert?
Ja, ja, die, die Organisation gibt's noch. Wir sind ja vor ähm etwas mehr wie fünf Jahren gestartet. Das war ursprünglich mehr eine Vernetzungsplattform, ein Bündnis
was sich die verschiedenen netzpolitischen Organisationen in der Schweiz auch austauschen können und gemeinsam an Aktionen arbeiten können und das hat sich jetzt weiterentwickelt
Wir haben Verein gegründet Ende letzten Jahres
und sind mittlerweile aus gemeinnützig anerkannt und versuchen nun nach und nach unsere unseren Wirkungsbereich und unsere Organisations, unseren Organisationsgrad auszubauen, um et,
besser und professioneller auch auf äh die, die Themen, die uns wichtig sind, angehen zu können.
Wie viel Leute sind da in dem Verein.
Ähm im Verein wir sind jetzt gerade erst gestartet mit äh Aufrufen, um wirklich aktiv Mitglied zu werden und es sind jetzt irgendwie etwa hundert Personen.
Hundert schon die Mitglied sind, so Vollmitglieder. Mhm. Okay.
Also das sind das sind wirklich die, die im Verein mitgriezen und dann gibt es natürlich noch den den Bereich, die wirklich aktiv sind und das sind die Leute, die ja auch schon länger dabei sind und da haben wir auf der, der internen Mailingliste sind irgendwie achtzig Personen oder so.
Aber auch die sind natürlich wieder unterschiedlich aktiv.
Aber das sind schon die Leute, die sich mit den Themen beschäftigen, die dabei sind, ähm viele, die an vielen Themen arbeiten und einige, die sich ein paar Schwerpunkte herauspicken, das ist natürlich sehr individuell.
Und an wie viel Themen setzt ihr euch jetzt sozusagen dran.
Ja, was uns gerade sehr stark beschäftigt, wo wir dann sicher gleich im Anschluss noch Schluss äh uns etwas vertieft äh austauschen werden. Das ist äh Überwachungsgesetze, das ist einerseits das gesetzbezeichnende Überwachung des Post- und Fernmeldeverkehrs kurz,
das Nachrichtendienstgesetz, äh, wo es dann auch um Überwachung geht, er für die Geheimdienste, das beschäftigt,
Beitrag beschäftigen und sehr stark schon längere Zeit, was jetzt aber auch gerade wieder sehr aktuell ist, das sind Netzsperren. Wir haben gerade
gleich drei Gesetzesvorlagen aktuell, die sich mit auf unterschiedliche Art mit Netsperren äh oder Netzsperren einführen möchten und auch da sind wir involviert
leider nicht ganz so stark, wie wir das wollen, weil uns auch natürlich von den Kapazitäten her sind wir etwas eingeschränkt
und versuchen das jetzt je länger sie mehr stärkt zu zu begleiten und entsprechend unsere Positionen einbringen zu können und diese Vorhaben dann auch kippen zu können.
Was ich mal fragen muss, wenn man jetzt sagt, digitale Gesellschaft, Schweiz. Ist das dann so ein,
Deutsches Ding oder äh gibt's da auch äh französisch-italienische äh was wir noch gleich die vierte Sprache retromanisch, also,
auch entsprechende Kontakte, Chapter, Leute, die diese Bereiche in irgendeiner Form auch zumindest ansprechen oder daher kommen.
Ja, leider zu wenig. Es gibt Kontakte
auf vor allem auch zu Einzelpersonen, aber es ist gerade so, dass diese Themen in der Französischsprachigen Schweiz eher weniger bearbeitet werden, das ist ähm G
eher weniger Interesse interessanterweise und die italienischsprachige Schweiz, die ist eh sehr klein und retromanisch sowieso, das ist,
ja verschwindend,
bereits. Also was interessant wäre, wäre die französischsprachige Schweiz, da gibt's auch gewisse Kontakte, aber leider nicht ganz so umfänglich wie wie das wünschenswert zwei Jahre,
der auch wahrscheinlich noch etwas Aufsensibilisierung, noch mehr daran gearbeitet werden.
Ist das, ähm kann man sagen, dass dass die französischsprachige Schweiz zumindest so in diesem Themenbereich da auch, sagen wir mal, sehr viel mehr diese Wahrnehmung hat, wie das in Frankreich ist.
Ich vermute ja, also in der deutschsprachigen Schweiz ist man sehr stark auf Richtung Deutschland ausgerichtet, da bekommt man natürlich viel auch über die Medien mit, ähm
also die Nachrichtenlage ist et cetera und in der Wellischen Schweiz ist sicher die Ausrichtung eher Richtung Frankreich, was hat
schon von der Sprache her, äh entsprechend gegeben ist und was in der welchen Schweiz auch etwas ausgeprägter ist man, man ist
Jetzt gerade im Bereich Überwachung nicht so stark abgeneigt, also man hat da eher noch etwas so diese ja,
ähm mir passiert schon nichts, wenn ich, wenn ich auch über das ist doch die Überwachung dient mir, das ist so nach etwas die noch eher etwas, die, die Vorstellung,
man kann das nicht für alle verallgemeinern, aber so ein Grundstendenz, dass man da noch etwas ähm,
Ja. Die, die Problematik nicht so stark sieht.
Na ja, wir wissen ja alle, Terrorgefahr ist groß, von daher nachvollziehbar, dass Leute auch äh teilweise so darüber denken.
Ja, das ist.
Das ist ja nur eine jetzt kann man sich auch nichts vormachen, das ist ja jetzt im deutschsprachigen Bereich auch nicht anders und das ist, ich finde auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar, dass Leute solche Positionen haben und ich denke, man muss sich da äh im aktivistischen Bereich auch einfach mal.
Wege überlegen, wie man seine Argumentation so überzeugend setzen kann, dass die eben solche Bedenken in gewisser Hinsicht auch berücksichtigen in der Argumentation, ne. Anstatt, dass
so, es gibt ja auch so, kennst du ja auch, ne? Es gibt ja auch so Leute so, die ja, ihr seht das alles falsch und ihr müsst das ignorieren, aber das ist halt schwierig, wenn das an die Ängste der Leute herangeht. Ähm, ich glaube, da hat auch noch keiner wirklich so eine richtig
gute Antwort drauf gefunden.
Na ja, das ist, das ist natürlich ganz klar so und das ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir eine deutschsprachigen Schweiz eine Mehrheit hätten, die äh die Überwachung ablehnen würde
auch die die beiden Gesetzesvorlagen, die wir gerade aktuell haben. Da da muss noch da müsste noch daran gearbeitet werden.
Kommen wir doch mal zu äh diesen drei von dir genannten Schwerpunkten eurer Arbeit
Wir haben ja hier jetzt auch in der Zwischenzeit mehrfach drauf hingewiesen, dass eben ein Referendum in Planung ist für oder ein Referendum gestartet wurde. Ähm um gegen die Novelle der ähm,
Wofür steht das B im Büff, das ich schon wieder vergessen.
Das ist das, also das Ganze ist ausgeschrieben, ist dass das Bundesgesetz,
Überwachung des Post und Fernmeldeverkehrs, also man man hört es auch etwas der der Namensgebung an, das gibt es schon länger, das ist kein neues Gesetz, sondern das wird dann halt nach und nach wird das ähm erweitert,
In der Kurzform dann genannt.
Genau und eine solche Erweiterung steht äh Stand an, ist vorgenommen worden und ihr wollt jetzt sozusagen äh da im Nachgang dagegen vorgehen.
Ja, also die das ganze Vorhaben, das ist bestimmt fünf Jahre alt, also ich denke zurück, dass wir ganz zu Beginn äh auch äh der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz schon ähm antworten auf äh
das Verfahren, äh, das Vernehmenlastungsverfahren, also wo die Gesetze vorbereitet werden, ähm, verfasst haben und mittlerweile ist das Gesetz jetzt aber im Parlament durch, also wir haben den ganzen Prozess begleite
und und versucht unser Bedenken anzubringen. Das war nicht allzu erfolgreich leider und nun wurde das Gesetz
äh verabschiedet. Das ist durch und im Anschluss, wenn äh beide Kammern
ähm dann ein Gesetz angenommen haben, dann
bleiben hundert Tage Zeit an dem sich fünfzigtausend Personen zusammentun können und ein eine Abstimmung zum Gesetz verlangen können. Und dies in dieser Phase von diesen hundert Tagen stecken wir jetzt,
wir sind eigentlich in der Schlussphase, dass die Sammelfrist für die fünf,
tausend Unterschriften, die läuft zum siebten siebten ab, also zu dem Zeitpunkt, also am siebten siebten müssen wir in der Lage sein, fünf,
tausend Beglaubigte Unterschriften der Bundeskanzlei abzuliefern und wenn das gelingt dann wird's 'ne Volksabstimmung geben.
Wo die Schweizer stehenbevölkerung darüber befinden kann, ob sie dieses Gesetz so will oder nicht.
Ja, heute ist der siebzehnte Juni zwanzig sechzehn ähm mit anderen Worten, es sind jetzt noch drei Wochen Zeit.
Es sind noch drei Wochen Zeit, es wird sehr knapp, wir haben diese Woche eine eine Hochrechnung gemacht und es sieht sehr sehr knapp aus. Also es muss noch ein,
Schluss äh vorgemacht werden. Wir gehen jetzt auch wie viel noch? Es ist schwierig zu sagen, also wir rechnen halt hoch, was was so wie die, also es ist sehr sch.
Wie viel braucht ihr insgesamt.
Insgesamt sind's fünfzigtausend.
Ja und ihr hab.
Das sind das sind fünfzigtausend Unterschriften, die auf Papier vorliegen müssen
Also es ist nicht irgendwie online, das kann man sich nicht klicken, sondern muss man sich ein äh ein Formular, muss man sich runterladen oder kriegt man zugesendet, das muss man unterschreiben, das muss auf die Gemeinden zur Beglaubigung, also da muss jemand eine Behörde muss sagen, jawohl, das ist eine stimmberechtig
Person in meiner Gemeinde, die hat da unterschrieben, die kenne ich. Passt ist eine ist eine Stimme oder ist eine Unterschrift, eine gültige Unterschrift und von diesen müssen bis zum siebten siebten
fünfzigtausend zusammen sein und wenn wir jetzt so hoch rechnen dann.
Könnte es knapp nicht reichen. Also wir müssen jetzt nochmals steigern, um,
die fünfzigtausend zu kriegen
und wir gehen jetzt einfach nochmal los, das ganze Wochenende sind nochmal Sammelaktionen geplant, also man muss da wirklich auf die Straße, es reicht nicht
Leute per E-Mail anzuschreiben und
klickt doch bitte mal hier, ladet ihr das Formular herunter, unterschreibe und schickt zurück, das ist Rücklaufquoten sind, dass sie oder sind da eher schlecht
sondern es ist auch heute noch so, dass Referenten oder die Unterschriften, die müssen tatsächlich auf der Straße sammelt sein, also man muss raus, man muss ein Kugelschreiber und Klemmbrett und die Formular dabei haben und ein gutes Argumentarium und muss auf die Leute zugehen und
sag mal, hast du schon unterschrieben, wenn ich dann doch bitte hier und dann kriegt man die die Unterschriften zusammen.
Und das werden wir jetzt nochmal verstärkt machen dieses Wochenen.
Also diese Erfahrung hast du aber auch gesammelt, dass wenn man wenn man so auftritt, dass man dann auch mehr Überzeugung.
Ja ja klar, dass das funktioniert natürlich schon. Man tut sicher auch gut daran, die ähm die die Lokation und die Zeit etwas,
äh auszuwählen, also sprich die dies die die konkrete Sammlung an.
Wird das Jahr. Und dann, also wir wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch dieses Wochenende ist ein großes ähm eine große Politveranstaltung ähm gegen ähm Atomkraftwerke. Da da werden
Tausende, vielleicht sogar Zehntausende Leute
erwartet und dass sie natürlich gute Gelegenheiten, wenn Leute draußen sind, die haben vielleicht auch etwas Zeit, sind,
politisch auch vielleicht eher etwas nahestehend, dass man da
dadurch durch die Mengen gehen kann und die Unterschriften sammeln kann. Es ist aber nicht so, dass die ähm einfach in den Schoß fallen. Also wir wir rechnen so, wenn man auf der Straße ist,
dass man so vielleicht zehn bis zwanzig Unterschriften,
kann, wenn man gut ist zwanzig, vielleicht auch mehr, wenn's ein optimaler Ort ist, vielleicht noch etwas mehr. Aber es ist, das ist durchaus noch Knochenarbeit.
Ja. Das heißt, ihr könntet auch noch ein paar Freiwillige gebrauchen.
Wir können natürlich noch freiwillige gebrauchen, das muss aber auch nicht wirklich organisiert,
trau sein, ähm, sondern da da kann auch jede Person für sich, die kann auf unsere Webseiten gehen, also es gibt eigentlich,
zwei wesentliche Wechselwebseiten, das ist eine die nennt sich Stopp, Büpf Punkt CH, das ist eigentlich das übergeordnete Komitee, wo alle Organisationen, die dieses Gesetz bekämpfen, vereinigt sind,
alle Bogen und wir haben dann daneben noch so aus dem Netzpolitischen Umfeld noch eine Sammelplattform, die ist,
Punkt C H zu erreichen und auch da gibt's Bogen, Argumentarien, auch ein kleines äh wie man, wie man am besten sammeln geht und auf BÜV Punkt CH,
es auch eine Seite auf,
alle Sammelaktionen aufgelistet sind. Also da finden Leute aus der Schweiz, die zum Beispiel in Basel zu Hause sind oder in Luzern oder wo auch immer, finden sie da. Leute
mit denen sie auch gemeinsam sammeln gehen können oder die Angaben waren die nächsten Sammelaktionen wo stattfinden.
Mhm. Kannst du mal
Vielleicht, weil wir das jetzt, glaube ich, am Anfang ein bisschen äh vernachlässigt haben, nochmal so kurz zusammenfassen, was so die Kern
Kritikpunkte sind, die ihr jetzt vorbringt und die quasi auch in so einer Argumentation auf der Straße, in dem Moment, wo man die Leute anspricht, muss man ja dann im Prinzip auch,
Überzeugend sein, ne? Man muss ja sagen.
Wasser,
muss man als Sprecher, darf man auch sprechen, ja? Natürlich. Äh, also beim BÜV geht es ja ähm darum, um die Kompetenzen der Strafverfolgung
ähm auszuweiten. Das ist jetzt im im Unterschied zum Nachrichtendienstgesetzt, dass wir im Herbst auch net eine Vorlage hatten, wo es um den Geheimdienst geht, ist es dieser Bereich, der der Strafverfolgung, wo das
das Pfiff umfasst. Und was wir da haben, wir haben
die Ausdehnung der Vorratsdaten speichern, also die Schweiz kennt schon eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die soll jetzt noch was deutlich ausgeweitet werden. Im ursprünglichen Vorschlag sollte sie von sechs auf zwölf Monaten ausgespro
ausgedehnt werden. Ähm, das konnte verhindert werden im Parlament
äh auch aus Angst vor dem Referendum ähm wurde in letzter Minute wurde noch von zwölf Monaten auf.
Wie wir es aktuell schon haben auf sechs Monate, das wurde so belassen, wie es ist. Aber es wir
dennoch ausgeweitet, weil bis anhin nur
an für ein Schlusszeichen nur die Access Provider, ne, vorat auch den Speicherung vornehmen müssen und neu sollen das sämtliche Diensteanbieter sein. Also
ist aktuell nicht nur
die Person, die den Internetanschluss zur Verfügung stellt, also die Firma, die dann ein paar Weite, die das zur Verfügung stellt oder den der Mobilfunkanbieter, sondern jeglicher
der irgendwas mit Kommunikation anbietet, also jeder Instant Messenger, Chat
ähm auch wenn's innerhalb von einem Spiel eine Kommentarfunktion gibt, dass alles, was im weiteren Sinne eine Kommunikation ist und ein Dienstanbieter in der Schweiz ist, muss in Zukunft.
Vorratsdaten speichern. Also das ist ein Teil der Ausdehnung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und dann kommen gesetzliche Grundlagen für
für immer es gibt 'ne
erweiterte Mitwirkungspflicht, also das heißt, dass sämtliche Firmen bis auch zu Privatpersonen
aufgeheißt der Behörden, die in der Überwachung vornehmen möchten, diese nicht selber
unbedingt ausführen müssen, aber sie müssen helfen. Also das geht soweit, dass wenn ich
in meiner Wege für das Netzwerk zuständig bin oder mein WLAN auf für die Nachbarn freigebe unter Umständen Zugang zu diesen Anlagen, das steht so im Gesetz geben muss, um unter Umständen auch mir nahestehende Personen dann
dass die überwacht werden können. Und dann gibt's auch, ja.
Ja, also während wir hier sozusagen so ein bisschen in die Endphase Störerhaftung äh ja, ihr dürft jetzt euer WLAN freigeben und ihr kommt unter Umständen dafür auch nicht ins äh Gefängnis. Ja, äh so an dem Punkt sind äh ist hier eher davon die Rede
wenn du da dein WLAN aufmachst und die Geheimdienste möchten gerne irgendwelche Überwachungssoftware installieren, dann hast du den auch noch Zugang zu deinen.
Anlagen zu gewähren. Genau, also so ist das, so ist das.
Das andere Ende.
Das ist, das ist wirklich krass, ja. Ähm und es geht dann auch noch so absurde Dinge wie
ähm dass man wenn man einen Kommunikationsdienst jetzt neu anbieten möchte. Also ich bin Start-up oder ich bin auch eine
bereits und hab 'ne Idee für 'n neuen Kommunikationsdienst, dann muss ich sechs Monate,
bevor ich mit diesem Dienst live gehe, muss ich zur zuständigen Behörde beim Bund gehen und muss diesen Dienst vorstellen. Wieso muss ich diesen vorstellen, damit sich dieser Behörde überlegen kann in der Zwischenzeit, wie diese
dann in Zukunft überwacht werden könnte. Ja das ist äh nicht auch nicht sehr wirtschaftsfreundlich, ja.
Das ist vor allem nicht startupfreundlich.
Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Es, also wenn man das Gesetz liest, dann dann sieht man ähm ähm,
der Geist, der da aus diesem Gesetz spricht, der soll die
Die Überwachungsmaschinerie möglichst umfangreich möglichst wie geschmiert am Laufen halten oder aufbauen. Das ist, das ist so die äh die Grundhaltung, die aus diesem, diesem Gesetz spricht. Es kommt dann auch dazu, es sind
pusten, die ausgesprochen werden können bis zu hunderttausend Franken, wenn man oder sind fast auch hunderttausend Euro, die ausgesprochen werden können, wenn man irgendwelchen Aren, ähm, Anordnungen der der Behörden nicht nachkommt, das kann
denn verlost einer Konzession sein für ein Mobilfunkanbieter et cetera, also das alles alles zeigt so diese dieser Geist,
dieses Gesetzes, dass es möglichst wie geschmiert
äh laufen muss. Es sind auch sieben Mal vierundzwanzig Stunden muss man ansprechbar sein für die Behörden, wenn wenn diese eine eine Überwachung vornehmen möchte, et cetera. Also das ist so diese ja.
Gab's denn da dann keine nennenswert, also oder habt ihr nennenswerte Unterstützung aus dem Start-up-Wesen oder sind die alle schon äh schon abgewandert und es gibt gar keine Start-ups mehr.
Ja, doch es es gibt
es gibt das durchaus. Äh wir haben ja auch ein paar Firmen in der Schweiz, die sich äh insbesondere auch so ja ein Teil ihres Geschäftsmodells auch äh sorry, etwas die Privatsphäre ähm
auf die auf die Fahne geschrieben habe oder
Teil ihres Geschäftsmodelles ist, ähm, das ist ähm im Inset Messingbereich äh aber auch bei den bei Mail Provide und da gibt es Kontakte, die unterstützen uns zum Teil auch, zum Teil ähm auch eher nur im Hintergrund, weil sie sich nicht unbedingt jetzt öffentlich äh in diesem äh in diesem
einbringen möchten. Äh aber das ist schon so
die meisten, die überlegen sich durchaus den Plan B, was was passiert, wenn dieses Gesetz so kommt, was, was passiert mit uns und das heißt dann schon, dass man sich dann den Geschäftssitz, äh, woanders hinverlegt.
Dann geht man einfach in Basel auf die andere Seite des Flusses sozusagen.
Unter Umständen, ja. Ja.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil im Prinzip ähm das spielt ja jetzt hier eigentlich auch schön noch mit rein mit ähm gescheiterten Initiativen. Ich glaube, zuletzt in in Indien, wo ja so auch so ähnliche Überlegungen mit Offenlegungen von äh Kryptographie
gefordert wurden, was ja dann wirklich schnell gescheitert ist und ähnliche Debatte gab's auch in Großbritannien, wobei da scheint's ja derzeit wirklich auch nur jeder irgendwie erdenkliche bekloppte Debatte zu geben,
Trotz alledem diese Forderung scheitert natürlich jetzt auch ein wenig an diesen Realitäten. Ähm das wissen wir ja auch, ne? Insbesondere Apple jetzt in seiner Auseinandersetzung mit dem,
BI, die ja da auch relativ stark die Wirbelsäule durchgedrückt haben und gesagt haben, so,
Nö. Wir lassen euch da nicht reingucken. Was ist denn sozusagen, ich meine, wenn jetzt dieses Gesetz,
Gültigkeit hätte, das würde doch im Prinzip genauso auch für die Etablierten Anbieter gelten oder gibt's da in irgendeiner Form Ausnahmen für große Unternehmen aus Amerika.
Ähm, nein, es gibt keine Ausnahmen, aber es ist natürlich so die Frage für wen Gesetz gilt
wenn eine Firma einen Sitz im Ausland hat vielleicht nicht mal eine Niederlassung in der Schweiz, dann gilt das Gesetz nicht. Das ist auch ein Teil der Absurdität dieses Gesetzes. Schlussendlich ist es eine
aus der der wirtschaftlichen Perspektive gesehen eine Schlechterstellung der Unternehmen in der Schweiz gegenüber all den Anbietern, die sich im Ausland befinden.
Ja, ich meine, genau diese Debatte gab es ja auch in den USA, also nach dem Motto, wenn ihr das jetzt hier bei uns einführen wollt, dann sind äh unsere Unternehmen benachteiligt, aber äh woanders findet das dann irgendwie trotzdem statt?
Genau, das ist natürlich die allermeiste Kommunikation, die findet dann irgendwo über Dienste und Firmen und und äh selber im Ausland statt. Das ist, das ist genauso.
Aber das hat bisher jetzt auch noch keinen gestört so. Also ich meine, äh wie gewebt sind Unterstützung in der Politik äh durch irgendwelche Parteien für euer Referendum.
Das gibt's in der Politik, es gibt sie auch in der Wirtschaft, aber die die Meinungen sind eher Minderheiten, Meinungen leider, auch das Gesetz ist im Parlament,
überraschend deutlich angenommen worden und das ist,
der Tatsache geschuldet, dass es zum Schluss hatten es alle Satt darüber zu diskutieren. Was eigentlich aber auch zeigt, wie schlecht das Gesetz insgesamt ist. Ähm, dass das ging durch
durch
alle möglichen Instanzen im Gesetz, also im in der in der ähm in Fern im im Verfahren, wie wie es, wie es zustande kommen ist, also das ging so,
lange bei den äh in den parlamentarischen Kammern hin und her bis es beinahe gescheitert ist. Also sie müssen eine Einigungskonferenz einberufen, weil weil das Ping-Pong, das das hat
fast nicht aufgehört und um das.
Und es zum Abschluss zu bringen, gibt es so das letzte Mittel, das ist eine Einigungskonferenz und die mussten die sie einberufen an der letzten Frage, ob dann die Fortdaten
auch tatsächlich durch die Daten auch im Ausland gespeichert werden dürfen und sie haben sich dann auch da noch,
gerungen, ja, auch im Ausland ist es möglich, einfach nur um das Gesetz zu retten. Es wollte schlussendlich war niemand zufrieden, aber auch niemand wollte es sterben lassen und dann haben sie in der, in der Schlossabstimmung ist es dann sehr deutlich.
Angenommen worden, weil einfach niemand wollte mehr darüber diskutieren. Niemand wollte er sterben lassen, es wollte es alle vom Tisch haben und das ist
Aber natürlich dann leider ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn sehr viele Parlamentarier und Parlamentarier in dem Gesetz zugestimmt haben, obwohl alle es eigentlich die allermeisten,
eigentlich nicht wirklich damit zufrieden sind. Und jetzt gilt es irgendwie die äh die Stimmung da zu dahingehend zu ändern, dass man halt
tatsächlich all diese schlechten Punkte sieht und eigentlich sagt, nein, insgesamt es es muss zurück. Es es ist ein schlechtes Gesetz,
aber
natürlich nicht ganz einfach zu zu bewerkstelligen, weil die die öffentliche Wahrnehmung ist natürlich ja, die Technologie entwickelt sich weiter selbstverständlich müssen die die Strafverfolgungsbehörden in verschlüsselte Kommunikation, verschlüsselnde Kommunikation abhören können, aber was was das alles im
das ist viele Leute nicht bewusst und auch nicht ganz einfach zu erklären und das ist irgendwie unsere Aufgabe, dass noch äh verständlich zu machen.
Letzte Nachfrage vielleicht dazu ähm da ja hier auch eine Ausweitung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh drin ist. Ich weiß gar nicht, inwiefern die jetzt
derzeit, also in wie inwiefern ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung derzeit schon Realität.
Wir haben eine sechsmonatige Vorartsdarte-Speicherung in der Schweiz seit vielen Jahren. Die ist schleichend eingeführt worden und dann sukzessive ausgeweite,
die besteht, die kann auch nicht mit dem Referendum abgeschafft werden, wenn das Gesetz scheitern sollte, dann bleibt die Vorratsabspeicherung, so wie sie jetzt ist,
ist uns seit längerer Zeit ähm ein Dorn im Auge. Wir haben von, dass es
Eines der ersten Aktivitäten, die wir innerhalb der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz angegangen sind
die Vorortsartenspeicherung zu einem Thema zu machen in der Schweiz und eine Maßnahme daraus ist auch, dass wir eine Beschwerde gemacht haben. Die ist aktuell noch immer hängig, die ist seit
Monaten bald ja anhängig am Bundesverwaltungsgericht in der Schweiz, ob,
diese überhaupt ähm rechtmäßig, also verhältnismäßig ist und da wir aber kein ähm
Verwaltungseinheit, wie sagt man.
Verfassungsgericht haben.
Genau, ähm das ist der Begriff Bundesverfassungsgericht haben, wie wir es in Deutschland und vielen anderen Staaten gibt
Wer das wahrscheinlich so sein, dass der Weg für diese Beschwertung bis zum europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte in Straßburg
reichen wird. Wo wir uns aber sehr gute Hoffnungen,
ausrechnen, aber das wird noch das eine oder andere Jahr dauern, bis wir soweit sind.
Ähm jetzt muss ich gerade mal ein bisschen äh grübeln. Europäischer Gerichtshof ist so ein äh Organ der EU.
Ähm, das ist auf Basis des Europäischen Menschen, wie heißt das? Die EME europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention genau in Straßburg, das ist nicht der europäische Gerichtshof.
Also wir rim.
Dass ich von Straßburg.
Also wir reden vom europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Denn EGMR, okay, dass wir das nicht verwechseln mit dem EuGH. Alles klar, ja ok.
Nein, da ist, der ist nicht maßgeblich für.
Nee, das äh hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, genau, ne? Genau, also europäischer Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte und das heißt, da kann das dann hinaskaliert werden und wenn's dann eine Entscheidung gibt, ist das in gewisser Hinsicht bindend dann für die Sche.
Bindend, also wir sind selbst beschwert dafür und wenn wir, wenn
unserem Gesuch Recht gegeben wird, dann muss das Bundesgericht in der Schweiz sein Urteil revidieren und
wenn wir Recht bei mir vollumfänglich Recht kriegen, uns auch vollumfängliche Recht geben. Das heißt, für diese sei es Personen müsste die Vorratensdeicherung ausgesetzt werden. Und dann kippt er und hört euch das Ganze. Das ganze Spiel, weil entweder müssen dann die Sechspersonen tatsächlich von der Vorortsdatenspeicherung ausgenommen werden, was technisch sehr schwierig ist und
alle anderen könnten dann ja auch nachziehen und das für sich auch in Anspruch
nehmen lassen. Ähm oder aber sie wird gleich komplett aufgehoben. Also das ist der Mechanismus oder der Hebel, der da angesetzt werden kann, indem ähm ein Urteil in in Straßburg erwirkt wird.
Also das hat dann ganz konkrete Auswirkung.
Gut äh lass uns zu dem zweiten Teil äh eurer Aktivität äh kommen, den du angedeutet hast, äh ein weiteres Referendum zum Nachrichtendienstegesetz, richtig?
Ja, das ist das Nachrichtendienstgesetz, eine Generabkürzung, das ist,
Die Überwachungsbefugnisse des Geheimdienstes, der Geheimdienst der ist ja ziemlich zurückgebunden in der Schweiz seit einigen Jahren, also in der Anführungsschlusszeichen zurückgebunden, weil wir unter unseren Überwachungsskandal in den neunziger Jahren hatten
in der neunzehn neunzig ist ja aufgefallen, dass äh der Geheimdienst
ohne irgendwelche gesetzlichen Grundlagen zu haben, von zehn Prozent der Schweizer Bevölkerung
Fischen angelegt hat, also Überwachungsdossiers. Und das hat dann natürlich zu Recht ziemlich viel Aufregung gesorgt. Das war ein veritabler Skandal
und das Gesetz, das im Anschluss erlassen wurde, das ist im Vergleich zu anderen Geheimdienstgesetzen in Europa und der Welt.
Eher restriktiv. Weil das natürlich noch etwas unter dem Eindruck dieses Skandals gestanden ist in der ne
Jahren und jetzt versucht man mit dem neuen Nachrichtendienstgesetz eigentlich alle diese Befugnisse, die dem Geheimdienst zu fehlen scheinen und die sie gerne haben möchten mit einem Gesetz
denn den Behörden oder dem Geheimdienst zu geben. Das sind dann auch wie beim Büt, dass man den.
Einsetzen kann, dass man immer sie Ketchup verwenden kann, dass man zugänglich auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kriegt, dass man
Überwachungen von E-Mail, Telefon, Post anordnen kann, dass man Wohnungen verwanzen darf, das geht
bis zu Auskunftspflichten von Behörden, wo man nachfragen kann, gebt uns Auskunft über dies und jenes oder dann auch
Pflichten, wo die Behörden von sich aus den Geheimdienst benachrichtigen müssen, wenn ihnen was auffällt und es ist auch
die Kabelaufklärung drin. Das ist der Teil, wo man versucht, die Datenströme
nach Stichworten aufzusuchen, das wird dann. Stichwort Kategorien geben mit je also Kategorien mit jeweils
zwei Dutzend Stichworten, wo dann der ganze Datenverkehr gerastet wird und wenn man hängen bleibt, dann entsprechen hochtopft,
das ist so etwas der der Umfang des Nachrichtendienstgesetzes, das Gesetz wurde Ende letzteren Jahres verabschiede,
Die Referendumsfrist für die Sammlung der fünfzigtausend Unterschriften, die erst Anfangs Januar diesen Jahres abgelaufen und da ist es uns gelungen.
Diese fünfzigtausend Unterschriften zu sammeln
Das ist bestätigt, mittlerweile und es ist auch bereits ein Datum für die Abstimmung bekannt
dass wir die Abstimmung wird am fünfundzwanzigsten September zweitausendundsechzehn, also in diesem Herbst stattfinden, wo die Schweizer Stimmbevölkerung sagen kann, ob sie das Gesetz möchte oder nicht.
Mhm. Wie schätzt du das ein? Die Chancen der Abstimmung.
Es wird schwierig werden, eine Mehrheit zu gewinnen zu finden, um es tatsächlich verhindern
zu können, dass
Tragische an solchen Abstimmungen ist, dass es sehr stark auch von der aktuellen aktuellen gesamtgesellschaftlichen Wahrnehmung abhängig ist,
wenn das im Herbst nochmals ein Vorfall ein ein Attentat etwas ähnliches
geben sollte, dass sehr nah der Schweiz ist, dann hat das eine große Auswirk
ähm auf die Abstimmung genauso wie wenn es nochmal geben würde im Herbst, also das ist etwas ähm,
Ja, darum auch etwas schwierig abzuschätzen, aber in der Grundtendenz ist es wieder sehr, sehr schwierig werden.
Die die Schweizer Bevölkerung noch davon überzeugen zu können, das Gesetz so komplett abzulehnen. Aber wir, wir nehmen die Herausforderung natürlich an.
Gut, auch da äh wünscht ihr euch natürlich breite Unterstützung und äh
Teilnahme. Wie ist so der typische die typische Wahlbeteiligung bei solchen Referenten fällt das vom Termin her dann mit anderen Referenten zusammen oder anderen äh Wahlen.
Ja, das sind immer verschiedene Dinge. Ähm die Wahlwahlen sind ähm unabhängig,
Was es aber hat, das sind immer mehrere Initiativen und Referenten, die gemeinsam zur Abstimmung kommen
und dann kommt es etwas darauf an, welche Vorlagen das das sind, welche Vorlagen, welche Bevölkerungsteile beschäftigen und dann verfallen die
die Teilnahme ist dann unterschiedlich hoch, aber meistens eher gering. Also es ist vierzig Prozent irgend sowas,
dreißig Prozent vielleicht, also ist eigentlich ja, ich würde mal sagen ausländische Perspektive wahrscheinlich erschreckend gering.
Weiß ich nicht, also
kennen jetzt die Zahlen nicht für Referenten, die sind ja hier äh deutlich seltener und nicht so ein, so eine, so ein, so ein regelmäßiges Ding, aber äh teilweise schaffen die dann halt auch ihre Quoten nicht. Also ich glaube
Man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass äh solche Referenten jetzt immer gleich neunzig Prozent der Teilnehmer ziehen und auch normale Wahlen sehen ja durchaus auch
'n Rückgang zumindest in Deutschland gab jetzt glaub ich eine Erholung, ich hab jetzt gesagt die zahlen nicht so richtig im Kopf,
ist mir anders halt so äh hin und her, andererseits muss man, glaube ich, bei der Schweiz dann auch sehen,
dass natürlich hier die die Zahl der Referenten, über die halt üblicherweise so pro Jahr zu bestimmen ist und wo man sich dran beteiligen kann, verhältnismäßig hoch ist.
Mhm. Ja, ja kaum.
Weiß nicht wie hoch die Zahl ist, aber es sind viele und ja, dass da nicht permanent alle immer wieder zur Wahlkabine rennen, kann ja auch irgendwie verstehen.
Ja, es ist äh das ist sicher so, wobei die die Hürde ist ziemlich klein, also wir kennen ja auch, dass äh die Möglichkeit zu Brieflichen Abstimmung
Äh ich halte es meistens so, wenn ich, wenn ich die die Unterlagen bekomme, dann reiße ich das äh auf und und nach meinem Jahr nein, äh Entscheidung und
schmeiß es dann gleich wieder auf die Post. Also es ist ähm sehr niederschwellig eigentlich. Man muss nicht
am Sonntagmorgens an die an die Ohren gehen und da seine seine Stimme abgeben.
Ja gut ähm dann erwähntest du noch,
Drei Gesetze, die in äh Abstimmungen, beziehungsweise äh in in der Anhörungsphase sind, die sich im weiteren Sinne mit Netzsperren beschäftigen. Sag doch dann mal was zu.
Ja, das sind tatsächlich drei Vorlagen,
die uns aktuell beschäftigen, wo und in unterschiedlichen Art Netzsperren drin vorkommen, das ist einerseits das Geldspielgesetz, da geht es darum aus ausländische Casinos,
ähm,
zu hindern in der Schweiz tätig zu werden und zwar geht es da hat es dann einen Schutz vor vor Geldspielsucht steht da steht da im Vordergrund das Gesetz ist,
am weitesten fortgeschritten von diesen dreien, das ist bereits in der parlamentarischen Debatte, das ist aktuell durch den Ständerer, das ist die kleine Kammer, ist das durch, das ist.
Praktisch oppositionslos angenommen worden. Das war,
diese oder letzte Woche ist das äh angenommen worden und geht jetzt in die große Kammer, da bleiben uns ein paar Tage Zeit, um diese Leute noch anzugehen, das werden wir in diesen Tagen machen oder sind wir auch schon, sind wir auch schon dabei. Ähm.
Ist das eine, das andere ist das Urheberrecht, da sind wir in der Vernehmlassungsphase, das heißt, das ist,
dieser Vorbereitungsprozess auf ein Gesetz, wo die die Interessierten Organisationen angehört werden, also da können alle, die sich äußern möchten, können sich zu einem Gesetz einbringen,
und die diesem Urheberrecht hat das ähm ein ganz großes Kapitel drin, das sich um die Bekämpfung der sogenannten Internetpiraterie beschäftigt und da hat es drei Punkte drin, wo es um Verfolgung von Nutzern geht,
dann auch mit Zugriff auf die Vorortsdatenspeicherung, wo es
Verfahren drin hat und auch die Netzsperren von äh für ausländische Anbietern wo
Material zur Verfügung gestellt wird, dass äh ähm dann äh unter Verletzung des Urheberrechts bezogen werden kann,
Und das letzte Gesetz ist das Fernmeldegesetz, da kennen wir seit
einigen Jahren bereits 'ne freiwillige Vereinbarung der Provider, dass man den, dass über DNS-Sperren Zugang zu Sides, wo Dokumentierte Cands Missbrauch verbreitet wird, ähm, gesperrt wird und das soll neu verpflichtend
äh für alle paar weiter gelten und das ist im Fernwäldergesetz vorgesehen und auch dieses ist in der Vernehmlassungsphase.
Und da werden wir mal schauen, wie weit man das äh,
noch verhindern kann. Ähm, Einschätzung ist etwas schwierig,
Ähm wahrscheinlich wird das Urheberrecht das umstrittenste Fall sein, weil es da sowieso auf das.
Das umfasste nicht nur den Bereich der sogenannten Internetpiratie, sondern ja auch viele andere Aspekte und da sind sehr viele unterschiedliche Ansichten da
Das äh Vertriebleistungsverfahren hat zu einer krassen Situation geführt, dass es in der Größenordnung von
tausendvierhundert Antworten gegeben hat, dann muss ich das mal vorstellen, als Behörde muss ich nun mit mich mit tausendvierhundert Antworten auf meinen Vorschlag, muss ich mich beschäftigen,
und das ist aber das zeigt aber auch aus wie wie stark um Kämpf das das ist. Also das wird nicht so kommen wie das aktuell noch gedacht ist weil weil sehr viele unterschiedliche Interessen da noch versuchen
zu zu verändern.
Tja, Mensch, du, ich fühle, ich fühle mich gerade richtig frei hier in Deutschland.
Gell, sag nur. Ja, es ist manchmal fühlen wir uns auch jetzt, was wir, wir stehen etwas an der Wand und müssen uns dann irgendwie wieder vorkämpfen und und all diese Themen irgendwie unter die Leute bringen, ja?
Ja, es läuft schon einiges. Und was dann schade ist, was wir eigentlich auch noch gerne machen möchten. Wir möchten ähm die die Netzneutalität äh verankern endlich in der Schweiz. Da gab gab's ja auch verschiedene Vorstöße. Und genau das Fernmeldegesetz, wo jetzt Netzsperren drin sind, wäre eine gute Chance gewesen, um die Netzneutralität
zu ähm,
festigen oder festzuschreiben und genau das wurde nicht gemacht. Also wir versuchen das noch einzubringen, aber das hat da leider nicht geklappt. Also es ist eigentlich ist das falsche drin im Gesetz.
Super.
Ja, so,
die aktuelle Netzpolitische Situation in der Schweiz nicht. Kein sehr erfreuliches Bild. Er ist leider so. Wir versuchen.
Vorgeworfen, dass wir immer so pessimistische Ausblick,
liefern und so. Ähm ihr müsst mal anfangen mit dem Podcast dann wird's ja noch schlimmer.
Um das Bild zu drehen, meinst, da hat er so, ja, nein, ich ich hoff's nicht, nein. Ja. Es ist ja, es ist die aktuelle Situation, die ist nicht gerade so erfreulich, die Arbeit wird uns nicht ausgehen und dennoch versuchen wir das mit
ähm ja doch mit äh manchmal auch etwas mit Humor anzugehen. Das bringt sonst auch nichts.
Gut Kehre, ich
Glaube, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut äh eingetütet, vielleicht äh lassen wir nicht wieder zwei Jahre vergehen, äh bis wir uns das nächste Update äh holen. Wir wünschen euch trotzdem viel Erfolg mit den ganzen gestarteten Referenten und sonstigen Initiativen,
Ninos hast du noch was mit auf den Weg zu geben.
Ja, vielleicht können wir noch kurz mit auf den Weg geben, wer Unterschriften sammeln, helfen möchte, wie wie kriegt man das jetzt am noch schnell hin? Weil also auf.
CH, genau ist.
Genau da ist es sozusagen alles da und man kann einfach losziehen, Argumentation gibt's auch in Form von Video und Text.
Genau, das ist alles auf Prüfpunkt C hervorhanden.
Also es gibt eigentlich keine Ausreden mehr, ne?
Äh sollte es nicht geben, nein, das sehe ich, dass sehe ich auch so. Jetzt ist die Zeit noch eine Woche um zu handeln.
Wie's Wettervorsage fürs Wochenende.
Ja, aber ähm jetzt wieder etwa.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist gut, gut, Sonnen.
Etwas besser, ja. Wir hatten auch Regen, wir hatten auch viel Regen, aber jetzt ist wieder besser, sieht's eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht aus. Alle lo.
Na, siehst mal, Atomkraftdemo, Atomkraftdemo, schönes Wetter, äh raus aus dem Keller.
Wir schaffen das.
Ne? Genau. Super. Dann.
Ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich, hab.
Wir danken dir.
Dann äh verabschieden wir äh dich jetzt erstmal und machen hier mit unserem anderen Programm weiter. Bis bald, tschüss.
Vielen Dank, tschüss.
Danke dir Kire, ciao ciao.
Gut, gehen wir von der noch nicht in der EU in die noch EU.
Du bist ja auch noch in der EU, ne? Wie fühlst du dich denn so in deinen letzten Tagen als EU-Bürger.
Ja bisschen, also könnte besser sein. Das äh ich habe, ich habe ja jetzt auch mal abgestimmt so. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich mal in einer Wahl teilgenommen. Das äh ist übrigens gar nicht so einfach, ne? Wenn man so aus außerhalb des Landes ist.
Stell dir das mal nicht so einfach vor. Weil das weiß nur, dadurch, dass ich jetzt sozusagen da mal wieder ein halbes Jahr gewohnt habe, habe ich überhaupt erst quasi das Anrecht wählen zu dürfen erlangt.
Weil ich sonst zu lange sozusagen diesen Land ferngeblieben bin und äh jetzt gilt das halt für fünfzehn Jahre.
Aber weil ich mich eben vor Ort dann äh für diese dort stattfindende Wahl, für die Parlamentswahl registriert habe.
Durfte ich jetzt mal wählen und hab jetzt tatsächlich erfolgreich einen Briefwahlzettel da äh eingereicht.
War ich bin dafür, dass sie bleiben, ne? Weil das wäre ein ja, ein epochaler Fehler.
Englands, kreise das vor allem England an. England ist das Problem, der Rest nicht so sehr.
Allein schon weil er zahlenmäßig nicht so ins Gewicht fällt, aber das ist halt einfach ein Englandproblem. Und es wäre halt auch für uns äh nicht gut.
Also das wird wenn's zukommt und leider sieht's gerade so aus. Meine man weiß man nie, Umfragen, das ist so letzten Parlamentsumfragen,
Parlamentswahlumfragen, die sind auch komplett am Thema vorbei gewesen, also da stimmt da einfach nichts. Von daher ist vielleicht noch nicht alles
Ähm in trockenen Tüchern, aber man sieht halt mittlerweile eine wirklich eklige Debatte, die äh Boulevardmedien, Mörder und so weiter hauen da drauf ein, also,
alle nur erdenklichen Gewinndinge der Situation versuchen sich da sozusagen,
gesund zu stoßen. Uns kann durchaus sein, dass dass die,
austreten. Das ist natürlich für sie eine Katastrophe, das wird sie äh wirtschaftlich einfach langfristig ruinieren und äh für uns ist es auch nicht gut.
Du kennst diesen ähm diesen Sketch mit dem Captain Enterprise da. Patrick Steward.
Was hat die EU jeweils für uns getan? Ja, das äh war ein sehr schöner Taker.
Also ich frage, ich frage mich halt, was hat Großbritannien jemals.
Das ist wirklich das ist wirklich die Frage. Was hat Großbritannien jemals für uns getan? Was was tun die gerade eigentlich jetzt für uns?
Die liefern doch wieder so Blaupausen, oder?
Ja, Investigatory Powerspill haben sie jetzt durchs Unterhaus bekommen. Ähm das Investigatory Powerspill ist die Idee,
Einmal alle Beschwerden, die es so über Vergehen und Gesetzesverstöße des GCAQ gab
zu nehmen und drüber zu schreiben der Bundestag möge beschließen und daraus eben ein Gesetz zu machen, dass all das was
vorher noch im Zweifel stand legalisieren soll. Also sie wollen ähm Internetprovider ähm zwingen,
den Surfverlauf und die App Nutzung zu speichern, sie wollen.
Sicherheitsbehörden befähigen, private und öffentliche Datenbanken zu durchsuchen, unabhängig davon,
die Mehrheit der Leute in dieser Datenbank irgendwie überhaupt eines Verbrechens verdächtigt wird. Also quasi die gleiche Idee, die man schon bei.
Der Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat also eine Verdachtsunabhängige Speicherung, wollen sie hier einfach mal auf alle Daten anwenden, die es überhaupt irgendwo gibt.
Und dann natürlich Polizei und Geheimdiensten die Befugnis geben anderer Leute Computer zu hacken
Man sieht, sie wollen nicht nur das, was sie bisher illegal gemacht haben, legalisieren, sondern offenbar auch schon so ein bisschen so für die nächsten zwanzig Jahre sich fit machen, ne. Mit äh mit so Eik allgemeiner Datenzugriff äh,
für alles, was Investition, Power ist,
Und das haben sie also jetzt durchs Unterhaus bekommen. Der nächste Schritt ist dann, dass das in das Haus of Lords geht.
Die können dann da auch nochmal drüber debattiert debattieren und die können den jetzt, könnten den zurückweisen, sie könnten auch Amens,
anbringen, also äh Ergänzungen um das Gesetz abzuschwächen oder Veränderungen vornehmen, aber eben in Form von.
Hinzufügungen.
So wie der Bundesrat äh auch ab und zu mal sagen kann, ja meinetwegen aber anders.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das.
Also es ist sicherlich nicht dasselbe.
Ich weiß nicht, was die deutsche Übersetzung oder die die korrekte deutsche Übersetzung für einen Emantment wäre. Ein hinzugefügtes, eine hinzufügen, eine Ergänzung oder.
Hinzufügung, ja. Hinzufügen an Ergänzung, Ergänzung, genau, Verbesserung.
Tja, aber das sieht, das sieht auf jeden Fall ganz spannend aus ähm es wird wohl dann auch nochmal vor den äh europäischen Gerichtshof gehen.
Weil in diesem Gesetz eben diese Speicherung des Surfverhaltens und so diese Vorratssantenspeicherung. Das ist äh obwohl Nee, das Recht, das wird ja gar nicht mehr von den europäischen Gerichtshof gehen. Entschuldigen sie, entschuldige.
So schnell kommen die da auch nicht raus.
Wenn wir uns vom Vereinigten Königreich den Vereinigten Staaten zu.
Dort beobachten wir ja seit längerer Zeit eine.
Einen Kampf um Netzneutralität, ja? Also die ich glaube, das gingen schon zwanzig elf los oder so dieses Thema, da habe ich das noch oder zwanzig zehn habe ich das auf Netzpolitik Org damals auch begleitet.
Die FCC hat also mehrmals Anläufe gemacht.
Regeln für die Netzneutralität festzuschreiben und bereits zweimal wurden der FCC diese Regeln vor Gericht wieder außer Kraft geklagt.
Und.
Letzten Anlauf machte die FCC dann im Februar zweitausendfünfzehn wo sie jedes Mal dann die von dem Gericht bemängelten Punkte so geändert haben, dass sie,
Die Einwände des Gerichtes ausgeräumt haben. Und in diesem dritten Anlauf.
Scheint ihnen das jetzt auch gelungen zu sein, denn in in Washington hat ein äh Berufungsgericht die Klage verschiedener Netzbetreiber jetzt zurückgewiesen.
Das heißt, diese Regeln stehen erstmal so fest, das heißt, da wurde noch nicht mal mehr drüber verhandelt, sondern die Klage wurde zurückgewiesen.
Jetzt können diese Netzbetreiber noch den ähm Supreme Court ersuchen, also das höchste Gericht.
Allerdings greift der Supreme Quart nur Supreme Code nur sehr wenige Fälle auf.
Jetzt kann man sich fragen, ob der Supreme Cottbus wegen der erheblichen kommerziellen, wirtschaftlichen Bedeutung macht, ähm da wird jetzt.
Spekuliert, aber im Moment sieht's erstmal für Netzneutralität in den USA in der Form, wie sie die FCC zuletzt festgeschrieben hat,
gerade ganz gut aus. Ähm das heißt
keine Websperren für rechtmäßige Inhalte, Anwendungen, Dienste oder unschädliche Geräte. Das ist natürlich hier, da sehen wir sofort mit dem Spitzenauge die zwei.
Abschwächungen, nämlich keine Wettschweren für rechtmäßige Inhalte, also sie halten sich das Sperren nicht rechtmäßiger Inhalte offen,
oder unschädliche Geräte, da gibt's natürlich dann auch eine unscharfe Definition, was jetzt am Ende ein schädliches Gerät ist.
Dann sagen sie keine Tempobremsen, also kein Strodling für legalen Internetverkehr.
Auf Basis rechtmäßiger Inhalte, Anwendung, Dienste oder unschädliche Geräte. Also,
Viele, viele Einschränkungen hier, aber ähm oder viele, viele Spezifikationen hier, viel mehr, aber eben keine Tempobremsen.
Und keine Bevorzugung, legalen Internetverkehrs gegenüber anderen legalen Internetverkehr im Austausch gegen Zuwendungen jeglicher Art.
Sei es selbst deine eigenen Inhalte und Dienste darfst du als Breitbandanbieter nicht bevorzugen und das ist, denke ich, hier schon das entscheidende, ökonomische Argument, ja? Zu sagen,
es wird einfach nicht der eine in den Verkehr gegenüber dem anderen. Bevorzugt. Der Teufel steckt wie immer im Detail und ich bin mir,
sicher, dass wir es auch, dass es hier eine Reihe an Kritik gibt, aber immerhin wenigstens wurde sie das schon jetzt nicht im ersten Anlauf direkt wieder,
weggeklagt. Insofern ist das eine zunächst frohe Kunde, die uns da,
aus dem Land der Freien äh erreicht.
Ja, es ist schon, es ist schon in gewisser Hinsicht total äh bedrückend, ja, dass ausgerechnet die USA,
äh das halt ausgerechnet oder das, also vor allem die USA ist äh sozusagen immer so ein bisschen als,
Erfinder des Internets, ja? Den, ich meine, den Status haben sie einfach es dann schaffen, kollektiv.
Sicht auch trotz aller Falken und trotz trotz aller Terror und Idiotie äh die da mittlerweile auch eine Rolle spielt,
dass sie sich am Tisch dann doch darauf einigen können, was sie, was sie eigentlich an ihrem Netz haben. Und was sozusagen der der Kerngrund ist für ihr funktionierendes Start-up Wesen. Was da natürlich ganz stark ist, ne und ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
welche Rolle äh Google zum Beispiel gespielt hat, also wie die sich da konkret eingebracht haben. Man könnte ja sagen.
Solche Unternehmen hätten ein Interesse dadran, genau solche Bevorzugungen zu äh.
Begrüßen, weil sie sind ja jetzt sozusagen die Stärkeren, aber ich vermute mal,
Selbst dort wird man sich äh nicht davon verleiten lassen, weil man einerseits sieht, dass es noch eine ganze Menge Disruption zu machen gilt, ja,
Kabelfernsehenbereich, Zugänge et cetera, da ist ja Google auch mit guten Fallbar unterwegs. Wir sind jetzt gar nicht so sehr auf Google äh festmachen, aber das sagen wir mal so. Typisches Bild,
während wir hier halt in so einer vollkommen verarmten
und vollkommen rückwärts gewandten Diskussion feststeckt, die im Prinzip einfach noch auf der Zementierung irgendwelcher Privilegien, Privilegien für äh ein Telekommunikationsunternehmen Staatsbesitz,
letzten Endes zurückzuführen sind. Und das ist halt irgendwie das Schweinische, ne? Dass man einfach an der Stelle einfach überhaupt nicht sieht, was man damit kaputt macht,
Und das finde ich, finde ich eigentlich ein Skandal, also das äh das geht einfach gar nicht.
Aber die USA kriegt das irgendwie auf die Backe. So und wie sich das in Europa entwickelt, das müssen wir jetzt sehen.
Denn in Europa haben wir ja jetzt gerade und Thomas hatte da schon mal drauf hingewiesen, was soll an dieser Stelle einfach nochmal tun, wenn das jetzt in Zukunft, glaube ich, noch öfter machen, die Berekkonsultation.
Und safe the Internet dot EU macht es uns sehr einfach ähm,
dort einfach mal unsere Meinung äh auch,
Andise Berik heranzutragen. Ähm in in der EU geht es jetzt insbesondere um die Fragen der äh Specialise Services, also diese bezahlten,
Überholspuren, die dann eben für bestimmte Dienste einfach eingerichtet werden. Es geht um das,
Traffic Management, also wie der Internetprovider in dein Traffic eingreift und es geht um das Zero-Rating. All diese Dinge sind nicht geklärt, ja? Das so wie ich diese FCC-Sache.
Lese, sind die da relativ ordentlich drin geklärt? Ich weiß jetzt wieder nicht, ob's nicht vielleicht doch noch irgendwo Anwälte gibt, die mich dann austricksen würden, aber ähm bestimmt, aber ich verstehe es jetzt erstmal so.
Und da können wir also jetzt mit Safety Internet dot I You,
uns Gehör verschaffen und dafür sorgen, dass die europäischen Regulatoren ähmnlich, mutig losgehen, wie die FCC an dieser Stelle.
Die ganzen Beratungen finden ja in Wien statt,
und ähm der Birik, also haben zumindest da gestartet, was sind da durchgängig äh dort stattfinden? Ich war ja in Wien und habe mal auch den Thomas besucht,
traf sich dann auch gleich, dass sie dann äh zum Beginn der Beratung auch eine Demo äh einberufen hatten, da in der Fußgängerzone. Wir haben das, glaube ich, auch kurz angekündigt,
Und ich war ja dann zufällig selber da, es war eigentlich gar nicht so geplant, ich war nur zufällig in dem Moment genau in in Wien und ähm ja, durfte dann auch mal die Flüssertüte an äh an den Mund halten und mal,
aus Podcaster sich klagen. Ähm Novom für mich. Wo ich bisher noch nicht gemacht nämlich so eine Demoredner.
Du hast echt da geredet.
Na ja, du musst halt mir das Ding einfach in die Hand gehalten, hat gesagt, ja.
Und hast du gesagt, willkommen zur Chaosradio Expre.
Guten Morgen, Wien habe ich gesagt oder hat keiner geantwortet. Ah, ich habe so ein bisschen gerantet, das geht dann schon.
Also war war ganz gut, aber ich äh plädiere stark für wenn ihr eine, wenn ihr eine Demo macht, ja ähm so auf auf ähm.
Öffentlichem Grund und ihr wollt die Öffentlichkeit adressieren, macht es nicht mit einem Megaphon.
Das ist einfach mal äh sehr unangemessen. Besorgt euch korrektes Audioequipment. Also was für Podcast gilt eigentlich auch für Demos.
Ja, die, das stimmt schon so Demos mit Megaphonen, machen äh.
Gar nicht. Nee.
Eindruck ist auch einfach fürchterlich zu hören, ja?
Man versteht nix. Du hast ein extrem äh engen Kanal und vor allem mittlerweile ist es ja nicht mehr so das Ding, ich meine äh Shops ja irgendwie im Baumarkt ein Bollerwagen, Haushalt irgendwie einen Akku, eine Box äh und einen kleinen Mischer drauf und fettig.
Ich will, ich will jetzt nichts hier vorgeben, wie zu demonstrieren sei, aber äh man kann sich da schon eine ordentliche Anlage holen.
Ja gut, aber wenn man jetzt mal mit so fünfzig People mal eben in der, in der Fußgängerzone auftaucht, dann ist einfach mal so ein, so ein, so ein mobile KleinpA, die man auch für äh überschaubares Geld sich zusammengeklickt bekommt, äh schon mal ein besserer Ansatz.
Ich finde das schön, wie man hier dann auch in der hundertfünfundachtzigsten Folge merkt, dass hier eigentlich nur zwei Nerds sitzen und sobald es irgendwas Technisches gibt. Pass auf, du musst.
Das kann man noch viel besser machen.
Kannst du nicht so das klingt scheiße.
Ja, du weißt ja, ich bin da, habe da so gewisse Empfindlichkeiten, aber ähm nein, ich will auch überhaupt keinerlei Aktivität hier in irgendeiner Form äh schlecht machen, ganz im Gegenteil, ich war sehr äh beeindruckt von der versammelten
Netzpolitischen Aktionsgemeinde, die ich ja bisher im Wesentlichen einfach über Thomas wahrgenommen habe, also in Wien meine ich jetzt natürlich
Und hatte da einen schönen Nachmittag und auch noch einen sehr ausführlichen mit vielen Diskussionen äh gespickten Abend.
In Metallip.
Unter anderem dann auch Metalle Per.
Schön, das ist schön.
So ist das. Ja. Findet statt.
Findet statt, Nessneutralität findet statt. Es finden aber noch eine ganze Menge andere Debatten statt.
Wahrscheinlich eigentlich thematisch nichts mit Netzpolitik zu tun haben, aber ähm trotzdem wahrscheinlich leider von einem Ausmaß sind, dass wir sie hier in der Sendung,
Mal ganz gerne besprechen möchten und zwar ist sicherlich vielen unserer äh Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer der Name Jacob Apple Baum bekannt, eine,
Ein junger Mann, der in sehr vielen dieser US.
Netzpolitischen und Hackeraktionen äh irgendwie involviert waren. Ähm,
der ist mir, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal so richtig aufgefallen, als er Julian Essorge auf einer Konferenz vertreten hat vor ein paar Jahren und damit als öffentlicher,
Vertreter Wiki Leagues auch in Erscheinung getreten ist, der es,
bekannt als persönlicher Freund von äh Julian Assange. Ähm er ist auch so etwas wie die Aushängefigur des Tor Project,
gewesen. Ähm,
hat in Deutschland mit einem Team des Spiegel den Henry Nannenpreis äh verliehen bekommen.
Nicht angenommen.
Dann aber nicht angenommen ah ich glaube der hatte ihn angenommen oder? Also ich die haben den angenommen und er hat dann nachher gesagt, er will den einschmelzen oder so. Ähm da ging es um die Recherche,
Äh zu dem Merkel-Handy. Ähm er,
Scheint da oder hat auch natürlich sehr gute äh Kontakte zu dem ganzen Snowden Team, also mit kennt mehrere öffentliche Auftritte von ihm, mit Laura Pointras, ähm.
Road Foundation.
Der hat so überall irgendwo seine Finger drin. Es war schon immer auffällig, dass er so ja so das aushängeschild ist. Und er ist auch im privaten äh Umgang oder im persönlichen Umgang muss man da glaube ich eher sagen, eine,
Eine sehr äh schillernde Figur, ja? Also er ist ein sehr eloquenter Redner und dass das denke ich Ata den entscheidenden,
denen das war so der entscheidende Faktor für seinen Erfolg auch, den er da über viele Jahre international hatte als jemand, der wirklich eine Rede halten kann, die die Leute am Ende,
über die politischen Themen äh die er behandelt nachdenken lässt.
Mhm. Auf jeden Fall. Dazu können wir noch, um's zu vervollständigen. Das Bild hat er ja auch noch so ein künstlerisches äh Portfolio anfangs vor allem als äh Fotograf, aber jetzt auch,
gerade im Zusammenhang mit ähm,
Überwachung, gab's ja auch diese schönen Installationen von Torautern, die in Museen betrieben werden, damit offiziell Kunst sind und damit nicht ausgeschaltet werden können und solche Spielereien. Also
hat es schon auch verstanden, sagen wir mal so eine so eine, so ein, so eine so eine Mischung von den Themen und,
der Öffentlichkeit herzustellen und das auch kurz zu erwähnen, er war auch ganz zu Anfang bei uns mal kurz.
Wir haben ihn mal in einer der.
Genau.
Politik folgen befragen.
In der neunten achtundzwanzig C drei, da sind wir halt auf dem achtundzwanzigsten drei am Mikrofon rumgelaufen. Da hatten wir unser Format noch nicht so gefunden.
Ja, also eine eine schillernde Figur, die aber das kann man auch sagen, innerhalb.
Der Community schon längere Zeit streitbar ist, also polarisiert mir insbesondere aufgefallen ist durch,
so ein bisschen divenhaftes Verhalten, ja? Also der war sich seiner besonderen Position schon durchaus äh,
gewiss.
Und hat dann auch eben bestimmte äh Privilegien für sich gesehen oder in Anspruch genommen und es gab dann,
häufiger mal Schwierigkeiten im Rahmen von Kongressen, wenn ihm der Zeitpunkt für seinen Talk nicht gefallen hat oder
er das als in Zensur empfunden hat, dass die vierte seiner Einreichung dann doch mal abgelehnt wurde. Also er war im im persönlichen Umgang bekanntermaßen nicht besonders einfach.
Das war so der Stand bis vor ähm ach so, es gibt noch einen Punkt zu erwähnen, ja, er war auch, denke ich mal, bekannt dafür, eine relativ ausschweifende,
Promisquität zu leben und die auch nicht besonders geheim zu halten.
Dass so bei mir zu dem Punkt geführt hat, dass ich mir irgendwie dachte so okay.
Glaubt ihr eigentlich, wie lange sowas gut geht, ja, wenn er mal über seinen Kryptofon, mit dem er ja dann auch, dass er auch immer präsentiert hat, dass er mit diesem Kryptophon jederzeit Studienassange anrufen kann, weil er eben sowieso zu Hause ist, ja. Ähm.
Wir gehen immer ran.
Dass er da nicht mal mit Julien äh sich über darüber unterhalten hat, wie man vielleicht längere Zeit als derartig exponierter Aktivist überleben kann. Hat er nicht getan?
Also wissen wir nicht, aber.
Vielleicht getan.
Leicht keine leeren rausgezogen weiß man nicht.
Also so viel denke ich wusste man einfach über diese Figur, wenn man da mal ein bisschen äh in diesem Bereich unterwegs war. Nicht einfach.
Aber in dem, was er oft Bühnen getan hat in der Regel eben doch ja brillant. Also,
ein wirklich enorm gut. Er hat doch dann immer mal wieder sich das äh irgendwie wirklich katastrophale öffentliche Fehltritte geleistet, wenn dann irgendwie mal ausgerastet ist oder so. Das waren auch Situationen, die man mitbekommen hat. Ähm
Insofern eigentlich jemand wo ich glaube viele Leute so ein bisschen den Eindruck hatten.
Mit dem will ich jetzt persönlich nicht eng was zu tun haben, wenn der da irgendwie rumschleicht, dann ist das in Ordnung, wenn er da mit seiner Possi in der einen Ecke sitzt so und der macht.
Offenbar scheinbar gute Arbeit. Ähm, es gab natürlich auch 'ne Menge.
Ja, also wenn jemand in so eine Position kommt, dann gibt's natürlich auch Zweifel daran, wie der überhaupt an diese,
in diese Rolle geraten ist, ja war ja schon ein bisschen auffällig, in wie vielen Projekten der überall drin war und überall immer der Frontmann war, aber äh es gab eben offenbar keinen ausreichenden.
Zweifel in der Menge an der,
im größeren Teil der Menschen, die ihn da gesehen haben und äh so hatte er sich da eben einen sehr guten Ruf international über die Jahre erarbeitet.
Mhm. Kann man schon sagen. Der hat jetzt. Mit unterschiedlichen Wahrnehmungen von unterschiedlichen Gruppen.
Manche nehmen das eine mehr wahr, manche nehmen das andere mehr wahr und dadurch hat sich eigentlich auch immer so eine Meinungsgemengelage vor allem ausgebreitet, dass wenn man sich dann mit nicht so sehr intensiv beschäftigt. Oder mal so ein bisschen indiferenter vorstanden und wusste so,
Okay, ich meine es nicht so, dass diese Szene an an tiefen Arm wäre.
Nein, ganz sicher nicht.
Nop. Trotz alledem kriegt halt jetzt seine Person eine ganz neue Aufmerksamkei.
Da hast also die ich mein.
Schillernde Figuren haben immer um die geht immer eine Kontroverse, ja? Und jemand, der an ein derartiges Level an.
Öffentlicher Sichtbarkeit hat, der kriegt das auch nicht, weil er äh zu Hause sitzt und immer der,
Freundlich und höflich andere den Vorrang des, ne? Das ist schon klar, dass du da ein gewisses Alphatier für sein musst, äh wie wie es eben auch ist. Nun,
lange genug der Einführung diese öffentliche Wahrnehmung von Jacob Apple Baum hat jetzt ein ein jähes, eine jähe Wendung genommen,
in dem
Ende Mai ein Einsatzblog-Post bei dem Torprojekt erschien auf der Website, in dem äh drinstand äh Jacob Apple Baum langjähriges Mitglied äh und Vertreter des Torprojektes,
hat das Projekt verlassen. Punkt. Keine.
Keine Erläuterung über die Hintergründe, keine Danksagung für Engagement oder so Einsatz.
Folgendes ist geschehen und das hat noch nicht mal so.
Das hat noch nicht mal das hat noch nicht so Welle gemacht, aber klar da ging's dann los.
Da ging's los, ja?
Und dann tauchte eine.
Von mir für mich Gefühl zeitgleich. Nee, aber es tauchte dann eine Seite auf ähm Jaycop Apple Baum dort net.
In der mehrere Person unter einem Pseudonym.
Situationen geschildert haben in den Jaycop Apple warum sich ihnen gegenüber,
arg grenzüberschreitend verhalten hat. Und zwar ähm ich glaube das waren.
Anfangs nur sexuelle Grenzüberschreitungen inzwischen sind auch andere dabei. Ich bin nicht mehr genau in der darüber im Bilde, wann, welcher äh Beitrag dazu kam, denn diese Seite hat dazu aufgerufen, weitere
Beiträge zu sammeln. Und da ging's also um Vorwürfe des ähm also sagen wir von sexueller,
Grenzüberschreitung bis zu Vergewaltigung, die sich dort gesammelt haben von mehreren.
Ich glaube oder ich vermute, weiblichen Personen, ähm die äh sich da,
Gehör verschafft haben mit dem Ziel vor ihm zu warnen. Gesagt haben wir haben diese, wir haben unter dieser Person.
Als internationale Community lange genug leiden müssen. Wir haben es nicht geschafft, diesem Verhalten Einhalt zu gebieten über lange Zeit und es ist jetzt einfach der Zeitpunkt gekommen.
Dem durch Öffentlichmachung und zwar radikale Öffentlichmachung ein Ende zu bereiten.
Wie das so ist mit anonymen Vorwürfen wurden die,
Sage ich mal, jetzt nicht von allen als für bare Münze genommen, in der Form, wie sie dort vorgetragen wurden,
Das änderte sich aber relativ bald, als dann auf dem auf der Talk Project Seite ein Beitrag von,
Cherry Steel zu finden war, der relativ jungen Executive Director Rin,
Projekts eine Frau, die eine lange langjährige Karriere bei der Elektronik Front hier Foundation hatte und dann quasi zum Torprojekt abgeworben wurde. Das Torprojekt, um das auch nochmal kurz zu sagen, das ist also das Projekt, das
dass die Entwicklung des Anonymisierungsnetzwerkes Tor vorantreibt.
Und dass es inzwischen auch eine Firma, ja, die sind äh haben einen nennenswerten Mitarbeiterstamm, die da auch äh,
angemessene Gehälter verdienen, einige sagen nicht angemessene Gehälter verdienen ähm,
und die die diesen Laden da am Laufen halten. Und die haben also mit äh Sherry Steel eine sehr äh hochverdiente äh.
Aktivistinnen aus diesem, aus diesem ganzen Netzbereich, die dort seit einiger Zeit die äh Zügel in der Hand hat. Und sie sagt in diesem Statement ungefähr, ja?
Um mal zu erklären, warum der bei uns raus ist, es gab seit längerer Zeit ähm Vorwürfe des,
sexuellen Fehlverhaltens wäre, glaube ich, die richtige Übersetzung, ne? Sexual Miss Condact ist das.
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten, dass ähm korrekt zu übersetzen, aber ich glaube, dass könnte passen.
Es ist glaube ich klar, was gemeint ist, wo sie also sagt es gibt, es gab seit längerem.
Probleme in diesem Bereich und wir haben äh wir sind nun mit Vorwürfen konfrontiert worden, die,
um einiges übler sind als das, was wir bisher wussten. Und aus diesem Grunde ähm,
arbeiten wir nun mit einer Rechtsanwaltskanzlei zusammen, um diese,
Situationen der sexuellen Belästigung bis Vergewaltigung am Arbeitsplatz irgendwie aufzuklären und zu regeln und ähm
Wir rufen weitere dazu auf, wenn sie mit diesen Menschen schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht haben, sich bei,
uns zu melden, bei mir zu melden, gibt ja ihre persönliche.
E-Mail-Adresse an, sagt aber auch so, wer ähm kriminellem Verhalten, äh wer strafbaren Verhalten zum Opfer gefallen ist, der möge bitte zu den Strafverfolgungsbehörden gehen.
Kurze äh Anmerkung ähm meint es, sie sei relativ jung, also.
Nein, sie ist nicht jung, sie ist jung beim Torprojekt, die ist unter ein Jahr und unter ein Jahr dort, aber sie müsste wahrscheinlich über vierzig sein.
Achso Jung beim. Okay, also sie ist schon. Ja, es ist sehr, sehr mindestens. Also es hier auf ihrer Seite ist hier von dreißig Jahren Erfahrung im Negal Business und so weiter. Also. Nee, das hat sich falsch verstanden.
Ja, ja, nein, nein, also dienstjung, sie ist dienstjung beim Torprojekt und ich weiß, dass es damals eine große Freude war, äh sie für das Projekt äh gewonnen zu haben.
Und das hat natürlich diese anonyme Seite, die ja irgendwie jedermann hätte äh betreiben können in ein ganz anderes Licht gerückt und dann ging's auch,
langsam.
Nahm diese Sache dann eben Fahrt auf, dann gab es noch ein äh Statement von Jacob Apple Baum, in dem er,
beklagt, dass es eine äh Rufwortkampagne gegen ihn gäbe.
Und ähm dass er sich dagegen zur Wehr setzen,
wird. Und in der beteuert niemals äh strafbares äh sexuell sich strafbaren, sexuellen Verhaltensschuldig gemacht zu haben, aber auch einräumt, dass er äh die Gefühle.
Von Menschen verletzt haben, mag und sich dafür entschuldigt hätte und auch in Zukunft entschuldigen wird. Das war so.
Sein äh Statement. Das hat natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt äh ein besonders viel Vertrauen in ihn äh zurückgegeben.
Und.
Gleichweise unemotionales Statement, was ähm allein schon mit dieser Spezialisierung auf kriminell schon seinen merkwürdigen Beigeschmack bekam.
Und es folgen dann offenbar Leute, diesem Aufruf der Seite Jancop Apple Baum dort nett, doch bitte weiteres Fehlverhalten dort äh zu dokumentieren.
Und das taten sie dann auch.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, die Seite ist von Anfang an mit so auch so Platzhaltern,
ausgestattet gewesen, das heißt es gab eine ganze Reihe von diesen Pseudonym und klickte da drauf und bekam dann eine Geschichte oder nicht, äh weil bei gefühlte Hälfte zu Anfang äh sozusagen nur Stand, das hier ist ein Platzhalter,
Zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses Beitrags
gilt das noch für zwei weitere Berichte. Die Mehrheit allerdings sind jetzt sozusagen auch mit Geschichten hinter äh hinterlegt.
Ja genau so dann wurden also mehrere äh Beschuldigungen.
Noch hinzugefügt und.
Eine davon wurde hervorgebracht und jetzt wäre es natürlich sinnvoll gewesen, wenn ich die Links vorher äh gesammelt hatte, hätte,
Aber es geht eigentlich wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht um den Namen. Da wurde haben drei Personen einen.
Augenzeugenbericht geschildert.
Dass sie am Rande des Kongress Zeugen geworden wären, wie ähm,
Jaycop Apple Baum an der Bar des Hotels, das sich neben dem Kongressgebäude befindet eine Frau äh
grenzüberschreitend behandelt habe. Die sei offenbar aufgeregt gewesen, habe sich unwohl gefühlt und ihre Tasche gesucht und er hätte nichts besseres zu tun gehabt als ähm
sie irgendwie anzufassen
Und als sie sich verabschiedeten ähm hat sie ihn dann noch irgendwie weggeschubst, als er sie nochmal umarmen wollte und dann sind die drei Personen,
ihrer Schilderung nach Couragiert eingeschritten und haben irgendwie Jaycop in ein Gespräch verwickelt, das und um der Frau die Möglichkeit zu geben,
das das zweite zu suchen. Und das haben sie in dieser Form auch äh geschildert und bei den drei Personen handelt es sich jetzt auch nicht um Leute, die nicht.
Die unbekannt wären oder kein Ruf hätten.
Muss auch dazu sagen, dass diese gesamte Debatte, die sich dann auf Twitter, auf Mailinglisten und äh anderen Kommunikationskanälen mittlerweile äh entfaltet hat. Jetzt schon wirklich heftige Züge äh.
Bekommen hat. Also es wurden,
Viele Maximalforderungen vertreten, es ist, es gab sehr starke Verfechter und auch äh Gegenredner, also
war sozusagen jetzt schon klar, dass das jetzt hier wirklich eine eine extrem starke, große, weitreichende Debatte ist, in der,
viele Beteiligte halt sozusagen auch nicht bereit sind von ihren Positionen. Ähm abzuweichen.
Darin kam dann eben auch noch diese Story obendrauf, die jetzt so sich nicht auf der Webseite von Jacub Appelbaum,
nicht von ihm, sondern auf der Webseite mit dem mit der URL Jay Club Apple Baum dort net, die er nicht von ihm ist, äh sich dort nicht fand und auch.
Glaube ich nicht, niemals dort befunden hat.
Okay. Das äh ich bin da ähm inzwischen ist das Thema äh leider sehr äh unübersichtlich geworden. Ich versuche das ein bisschen zu sortieren. Also dieses Statement hat,
In seiner damaligen Erscheinung nochmal,
auch Zweiflern, dass an diesen Vorwürfen etwas dran ist, noch einigen äh Wind aus den Segeln genommen, zunächst.
Weil hier eben renommierte Personen das äh geschildert haben. Dann erschien.
Das Statement dieser Person, der betroffenen jungen Dame, die dort als äh Opfer von Belästigung äh.
Geschildert wurde und sie erzählte eine ganz andere Geschichte, nämlich die, dass sie eben seit längerer Zeit mit dem
Jaycob befreundet und irgendwie auch in andere Form aktiv ist und es ganz im Gegenteil als sehr angenehm empfunden hat dort mit ihm und
Seiner Possi da die Zeit in diesem Hotel zu verbringen und dann sogar sagte es das unschönste Erlebnis,
sei gewesen, dass eben ihre Verabschiedung von äh von Jaycop.
Gestört wurde, was sie sogar dazu veranlasst hat, dann ähm später wiederzukommen in dieses Hotel und noch alleine an der Bar irgendwie ein Getränk zu trinken. In der Hoffnung, er würde nochmal wiederkommen, was wiederum die anderen
empfunden hatten als die ist so fertig, die setzt sich nochmal in die Hotelbar und zimmert sich ein so ungefähr. Ähm.
Diese Veröffentlichung war natürlich schon insofern bedeutsam, weil.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt sehr viel in Medien dann darüber berichtet worden war. Äh und zwar über genau diesen Fall, denn.
Während sich anfangs mit dieser anonymen Seite nur, sage ich mal, die mutigsten der Internetseiten an das Thema herangetraut hatten, war es dann in dem Moment, wo äh Sherry Steel und andere,
Bekanntere Vertreter da eben Vorwürfe erhoben haben, so dass dass sie gesehen haben, okay, jetzt können wir, jetzt können wir darüber schreiben, ne? Das ist hier offenbar nicht nur eine eine Schmierkampagne von anonym, äh sondern hier ist was dran.
Im weiteren Verlauf sind dann aber die Personen, die auf der Jaycop Apple Baum dort Netzseite anonyme,
Schilderung hervorgebracht hatten, hervorgekommen und dabei handelt es sich jetzt auch nicht um Leute, die keiner kennt, ganz im Gegenteil, das sind ähm Bekannte,
Verdiente jahrelange Aktivistinnen.
Mitarbeiterin des Torprojektes. Ähm bisher, die sich da äh zu Wort gemeldet haben, die ich ähm.
Auch persönlich nicht gut, aber immerhin kenne und wo ich mir sehr sicher bin, dass die äh da wohl überlegt, handeln und sicherlich nicht Unsinn erzählen,
Weil die sich natürlich der Sprengkraft dieser gesamten Geschichte seit Jahren bekannt sind, was ja auch,
Offenbar der die Sache ist, die dazu geführt hat, dass das überhaupt so lange passieren konnte. So scheint es, aber da kommen wir nachher zu.
Und jetzt kriegen wir noch weitere Informationen, die so die Vergangenheit betreffen. Und zwar gab es ähm.
Offenbar zweitausendfünfzehn schon mal eine kurzfristige Suspendierung, die Jakob Apple Baum bei Tor erfahren hat, wo er irgendwie für
mehrere Wochen vom Dienst freigestellt wurde, um sich mal Gedanken zu machen und ihm auch schon mit einer Untersuchung der Vorwürfe gegen ihn äh gedroht wurde und er äh gebeten wurde, sich einem,
Programm zu unterziehen, dass sein Verhalten in irgendwelche halbwegs vertretbaren Bahnen,
bewegen soll. Es gab dann ähm eine Ausladung, eine offizielle Auswertung Ladung vom Tor die Welloper Meeting, das im März in Valencia stattfand.
Da fiel mir das schon auf, dass der nicht da war.
Aber du wusstest zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht, warum.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich es noch dort erfahren habe oder erst dann, als ich wieder in Berlin war. Ich habe.
Aber es war nicht so, dass man dahinten ja okay, aber ist nicht so, dass das jeder wusste und dass alle darüber geredet haben, dass er explizit ausgeladen worden sei.
Gehe davon aus, dass das die die Tor-Community schon sehr klar wusste. Ähm.
Zu der ich aber auch nicht gehöre, ich war ja wegen des Internet Freedom Festivals da und hab dann da eben in dem Rahmen Bekannte getroffen, das war da jetzt nicht,
Das Thema Nummer eins, aber spätestens seitdem war irgendwie klar, da ist was im Busch. Und ähm,
Diese Geschichten kommen eben jetzt auch so in ihrer, in ihrer Gänze heraus und dann hat äh zuletzt jetzt äh Villad Blue eine sehr bekannte Autorin zu.
Ja, so den Themen Hacking und Sexualität, das sind glaube ich so ihre,
Dinge über die sie schreibten sehr lange ähm Beschreibung veröffentlicht, wie sie
Jaycop schon vor zehn Jahren in äh San Francisco erlebt hat und äh mehrere unangenehme Situationen mit ihm geschildert, wie er sich da halt schon am Arbeitsplatz ähm verhalten hat in,
sexuelle, unangemessener Weise und das war eben von äh so ein Kinki Laden, also die die haben da schon so BDSM Zeug verkauft und selbst da hat er es geschafft, sich irgendwie äh,
quasi in einer Form zu verhalten, die nicht vertretbar ist, wo man ja sagen würde, dass da vielleicht ohnehin schon, sage ich mal, die Leute nicht mehr mit mit strengen,
Katholischen Moralvorstellungen an ihn rangehen, die ja äh die er ohnehin gerissen hat, aber das ist ja auch nicht das Thema, sondern er hat es eben in diesem Kreise schon geschafft, Grenzen massiv zu überschreiten über jeden Zweifel hinaus ein Verhalten an den Tag zu legen, dass man,
nirgendwo jemals hätte, dulden dürfen.
Und jetzt stehen wir eben vor der Situation, dass dieses Verhalten aber offenbar,
anscheinend über zehn Jahre geduldet wurde, ja? Und das ist äh das geschildert wird, dass nun Menschen hervortreten, die sagen, sie wussten da auch schon seit Jahren von.
Leute, die dem, die ihm auch nicht nahe sind und äh um die Vorwürfe jetzt nochmal so zusammenzufassen, es geht also hier um einmal so einen Pulliing, also wirklich einfach das schlecht behandeln von Menschen.
Ausnutzen von eigener Macht und das ist von eigener Sache. Mhm.
Ausnutzen von eigener Macht. Ähm auch Einflüssen von Angst bedrohen. Ähm diese Dinge.
Wie gesagt, das war äh schon längere Zeit irgendwie schwer zu übersehen, wie er sich verhält. Ähm sexuelle Belästigung,
Vergewaltigung und dann eben das geht grade noch so ein bisschen unter äh die Plagisierung,
von anderer Leute Arbeit, wo so ein bisschen gesagt wird, dass also was weiß ich, Sicherheitsforscher,
Sagen wir mal, Bahnbrechende Ergebnisse gefunden haben und sich dann ähm Jacob Apple Baum ihn angedient hat, doch äh mit auf die Bühne zu gehen, weil sie ja so unerfahren sind und sie sich am Ende halt wiederfinden
auf einer Bühne, wo irgendwie Jaycop äh fünfundneunzig Prozent Redezeit hat und alle äh Medieninterviews gibt und sie sich dann
eben um ihrer Arbeit ein bisschen betrogen sehen. Das sind Dinge, die müssen auch nochmal diskutiert werden. Im Moment werden.
Andere Themen diskutiert.
Und jetzt habe ich mich bemüht, bis hierhin habe ich mich bemüht, objektiv die Sachen zu schildern. Ich werde mich auch weiterhin bemühen.
Wenn man in so einer Gemengelage ist und wenn du eine Person hast, die eben so,
Stark in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung steht, dann ist natürlich die.
Die Abhandlung dieser Dinge in in den Diskussionskanälen bei Weitem nicht so,
emotionslos wie es bitter notwendig wäre und ist natürlich auch verständlich. Ja, du hast hier die betroffenen Personen nicht wenige davon.
Wenige davon, die jetzt, sage ich mal, mit strafrechtlich relevanten äh Vorwürfen,
da sind aber eine ganze Menge von Personen, die ähm,
denen ein Verhalten widerfahren ist, was eben einfach nicht zu tolerieren ist, ja? Äh irgendwelche Bloßstellungen in der Öffentlichkeit ähm.
Unschöne sexuelle Annäherung, also richtig ekelig, ja? Und die haben das offenbar ähm.
Lange Zeit nicht. In irgendeiner Form so regeln können, dass es aufhört,
und wurden dazu gezwungen, letztendlich diese öffentliche Kampagne zu fahren.
Wo man sich grob vorstellen kann, wie das auf den,
Jaycop Apple Baum wirkt. Der den wird's jetzt gerade nicht besonders gut gehen. Der steht gerade in einem öffentlichen Licht, was einfach mal ihn,
Ich denke endgültig jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit ruiniert hat und der Mann hatte nur die Öffentlichkeit und hat nur dafür äh gelebt und gearbeitet, wenn er mal gearbeitet hat. Ähm.
Dann gibt es eine Fraktion, die in, in der Lage, die in der Gemengelage dieser Vorwürfe.
Äh im Prinzip so eine, kein Zweifel, keine Prüfung, maximale Strafepolitik fährt, ja, sie sagen so, was das Opfer hat Recht, die Opfer, wer Opfer ist und etwas schildert, hat Recht.
Und ähm die natürlich den Punkt auf ihrer Seite haben, dass es einfach zu viel ist, ja? Wenn da jetzt mal ein eine Situation ähm.
Schlecht geprüft von Menschen an die Öffentlichkeit getragen wurden, die in meinen Augen da jetzt auch jegliche,
ähm jegliches Vertrauen komplett verspielt haben. Ja, ist egal, wenn es äh hundert Vorwürfe gegen eine Person gibt und du trägst einen hundert Ersten vor und der ist nicht ordentlich geprüft, dann.
Hast du das Vertrauen in dich verspielt? Da bin ich.
Wie zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit äh Redison Hotel. Genau. Normal, die natürlich problematisch ist. Was man auch sagen muss, also die Leute, die jetzt.
Teilweise auch sehr laut, auch sehr drängend in dieser äh Diskussion teilnehmen. Also die anderen Gruppen dazu drängen, irgendein,
bestimmtes Reaktionsverhalten an den Tag zu legen
an mit bestimmten Maßstäben, die an die Art und Weise dieser Reaktion auch herangelegt wird. Gerade bei größeren Gruppen.
Ignoriert in meinen Augen auch oft einfach die Tatsache, dass viele Leute.
Auch einfach jetzt erstmal mit dieser Situation erstmal bekannt machen müssen, ja? Also meine,
erscheint am laufenden Mittag wieder ein neues Statement, wird wieder neuer Blickwinkel eröffnet, weitere Details hinzugefügt, kommentiert, äh, gegen Rede gehalten et cetera und ähm,
Ich zum Beispiel bin irgendwie seit zwei Wochen dabei als ich die ganze Zeit nur so ist die Zeit überhaupt noch hergibt, äh diesen diesen Nachrichtenstrom zu folgen,
um mir da ein Bild zu machen und ich denke, das geht auch vielen äh gerade so, zumal man eben auch einfach auf einmal auf Dinge stößt, wo man sich denkt so,
So, wusste ich gar nicht. Interessant, ganz neue Perspektive das Ganze zu bewerten.
Dass das auf jeden Fall ähm und es passieren dann eben auch,
Wie gesagt, so Sachen wie wenn dann eben Leute ein nicht ausreichend geprüften Vorwurf vorbringen. Und zwar so, dass dass der in den Medien behandelt wird und zum Schaden.
Dieser Person führt, ja. Und sich danach herausstellt, dass das eine.
Dass das eine Ente war, dann tun die niemanden, damit tun die niemanden einen Gefallen, ne? Also den ich gehe, also es gibt wahre Opfer,
Und das sind die, die auch jetzt da,
mit ihrem Namen stehen. Und auf dieser Seite Jaycop Apple Bound Adnet, ich gehe davon aus, dass da am Ende keiner mehr anonym sein wird. Und äh da wir da ich gehe auch davon aus, dass da noch Sachen kommen werden, ja? Und denen hast du damit keinen Gefallen getan. Weil plötzlich ihre Geschichten,
in in Misskredit geraten. Ja, also niemand, niemandem ist geholfen, wenn man da jetzt,
Schnellschüsse, Schüsse zieht, ja? Es ist übrigens auch niemandem geholfen,
wenn dann äh mit Graffiti an Jaycops hausgesprüht wird. Äh hier wurden ein Vergewaltiger.
Mit irgendwie Pfeil auf das falsche Fenster.
Nochmal nochmal so ein extra Nummer ist. Ja genau, also das.
Aber du bist, du bist.
In zwei Sprachen.
In zwei Sprachen, aber es ist also die die wer auch immer das geschrieben hat, hat entweder die extra die falsche Fährte in Richtung,
Englischer Muttersprachler gelecht oder ähm verrät sich dadurch, dass halt der Satz ist ein Vergewaltiger wohnt hier, was eben Deutsche nicht geschrieben hätten,
Ne, es ist eine Rapislifts hier und daneben nochmal die Google Trendslate-Übersetzung. Ist aber auch egal. Ja, also das ist eine selbstverständlich ist irgendwie haben.
War ganz vor dem Kollateralschaden abgesehen, dass die Person, die nun hinter diesem mit dem Pfeil gekennzeichneten Fenster wohnten, nun wirklich mit dieser Geschichte nun wirklich überhaupt nichts zu tun hat. Also keine Ahnung, aber schön ist das nicht, ne?
Nein, da ist halt also da ist auch wieder niemand mitgeholfen, weil man mit solchen äh radikal Aktionen eben jene in Misskredit bringt, die hier einfach mal ein Problem.
Einfalle mal aus der Welt schaffen wollen. Und es gibt natürlich Leute, äh die sagen, okay, das Problem aus der Welt schaffen auf jeden Fall.
Aber dann lass uns das doch genauso besonnen tun, wie wir sonst versuchen zu agieren.
Und jetzt hier bitte nicht irgendwie Wände vollsprühen, sondern in Ruhe.
Gucken wie sich hier der Staub legt und dann die entsprechenden Konsequenzen ziehen. Das geht aber natürlich anderen dann auch nicht schnell genug, dass du es gerade angesprochen und dann hast du natürlich noch so eine Reihe an ich sage mal,
Dreck mit Draufwerfern, ja? Die ähm,
die dann irgendwie sagen, ja und außerdem damals vor fünf Jahren hat er sich mir gegenüber auch unfair verhalten, ja? Was schön und gut ist, aber eben dann auch irgendwann, wenn die Vorwürfe, sage ich mal, zu ungewichtig werden und zu irrelevant,
eben auch.
Keine öffentliche Relevanz mehr hat, ja? Und eben dann wieder diesen diesen Eindruck erweckt, dass hier einfach eine eine Charita-Assistination stattfindet, wovon ich erstmal nicht ausgehe.
Dann hattest du das war dann nochmal ähm sehr skurril äh Solidaritätsbegründungen. Da gab's also dann eine Seite relativ früh äh unter der Domain Hour Respons dot org,
wo ähm zwölf weibliche Personen.
Sich im Prinzip ähm für ich will nicht sagen für Jaykopf verbürgen, aber sagen, okay, wir haben,
ihn. Wir kennen ihn seit längerer Zeit. Und wir haben hier den Eindruck einer koordinierten und einseitigen an,
Attacke auf seinen, auf seinen Cara, auf seine Persönlichkeit und seine Arbeit und wir haben,
andere Erfahrungen mit ihm gemacht und äh finden, dass hier eine evidenzbasierte Diskussion stattfinden muss. Also sie sagen nicht, wir können uns das überhaupt nicht vorstellen, aber sie sagen schon, dass sie glauben, dass hier ein bisschen
die Sachen heißer gekocht werden als sie gegessen gehören,
Und das sind auch einige äh Personen, die durchaus bekannter sind in und eine Reputation genießen.
Und ich versuche jetzt einfach mal immer keine Namen zu nennen und dann machen wir es hier auch nicht, kann man wen.
Hilft jetzt nichts.
Kann sich das anschauen. Ähm dann haben noch weitere Personen das äh gezeichnet. Hm.
Die kriegen natürlich auch dafür jetzt wieder.
Was gezeichnet.
Kritik äh also mitunter mit unterschrieben.
Unterschrieben. Ja, okay. Mhm. Mhm.
Und dann hast du noch so eine in dieser gesamten,
In diesem gesamten sozialen Netzwerken natürlich auch dann noch so alte Feindschaften, die dann da auch noch mit reingezogen werden, ne. Da werden dann also äh Organisationen oder Veranstalter äh beschuldigt ähm.
Davon ist jetzt CC auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass äh wir natürlich jetzt mit der Frage konfrontiert werden, erklärt doch mal bitte, wieso der Typ irgendwie seit mindestens fünf Kongressen jedes Mal bei euch auf der Bühne waren,
Und ähm ihr da nichts äh von gewusst haben wollt. Ähm da geht's also jetzt richtig rund.
Dann gibt's natürlich noch so eine.
Und in Dubio Pro Reo-Fraktion, die also sagt, okay, nee, wir müssen uns hier mal auf irgendeine Form von vernünftigen Prozessen,
Zumindest berufen, der die Forderung Glaube den Opfern und zielt die Konsequenzen äh ist natürlich eine.
Die mit der man in der Vergangenheit die Menschheit äh etwas schlechter Erfahrungen hatte, weshalb wir jetzt eben dieses äh Rechtssystem haben mit dem wir seit einigen Jahren,
ganz okay zurechtkommen, wo es eben,
Beweise oder Zeugenaussagen oder sonst was geben muss und dann eben eine Verurteilung stattfindet. Und es gibt aber natürlich auch auf der anderen Seite.
Eine Menge an Argumenten, viele davon gut, dass man sich eben diesen Rechtssystem nun in der Form nicht zuwenden kann.
Also in den Fällen ist es wirklich schwierig und es ist halt hier auch jetzt keine juristische Auseinandersetzung, die hier gesucht wird, das sagen auch die Betroffenen selber mindestens in einem Beitrag, ist das ja auch etwas ausführlicher dargestellt worden.
Ist der von Eis ist.
Dass es genau das ist ähm was übrigens auch sehr interessant fand. Das ist ja auch durchaus Bestrebung gegeben hätte.
Ihm gegenüber.
So eine Situation zu schaffen, in der es gar nicht erstmal um eine Verurteilung geht, sondern dem ihm sozusagen angeboten wurde. Hier, das muss aufhören,
Aber wir wollen nicht äh auch nicht vernichten, sondern wir sind bereit, dass wenn du dich.
Einlässt auf eine bestimmte Form der Bearbeitung dieser Probleme,
Wenn das jetzt therapeutische Maßnahmen, Gespräche, was auch immer, es wurde dann noch mit einem Beispiel einer anderen Geschichte sozusagen erklärt, wie es hätte laufen können und wie es in dem Beispiel gut gelaufen ist. Dies sei von ihm,
abgelehnt worden und das nicht einfach nur mit so eine, sondern eben auch gleich wieder mit äh Drohungen,
sodass das eben nicht gefruchtet hat so, ne. Sodass ich eben jetzt bei vielen Beteiligten eben jetzt auch so eine na dann.
Halt nicht so äh Haltung eingestellt hat.
Ja und jetzt hast du also da sehr fundamentale Positionen, die alle nicht bereit sind, aufeinander zuzugehen.
Eine Sache noch und ähm in der Gänse, also diese Avancen gab es und,
ist halt auch grundsätzlich einfach so, in dem Moment, wo es um sexuelle äh Missetaten geht.
Da ist einfach Polizei und normale juristische Prozess nicht unbedingt immer,
die richtige Antwort, das hat sich einfach an vielen Fällen gezeigt, das mag auch funktionieren, das mag aber auch genauso in die Hose gehen, das ist halt für die Opfer eine extrem bedrückende Situation, dass äh ne
macht alles öffentlich und verschlimmert die Situation, sodass viele eben dazu auch überhaupt gar nicht bereit sind. Aber die hier klang eben auch an,
da ist es darum einfach primär erstmal auch gar nicht ging.
Ja
Was mich an dieser Sache jetzt wirklich interessiert und was das ist, worauf wir eine Antwort finden müssen, ist.
Erstens, wie gehen wir jetzt mit dieser mit diesem Sachverhalt um? Das ist erstmal relativ klar, der ähm.
Wir machen es jetzt mit wir.
Also wenn ich jetzt wir sage, dann gehe ich mal einfach so als wir als.
Community.
Community von Communitys, die,
sich in irgendeiner Form den politischen Idealen zugehörig fühlt oder der technischen Szene zugehörig fühlt, die von diesem Problem nun betroffen ist.
Und es geht hier eben nicht nur nicht nur um eine Person.
Es geht hier darum, dass das überhaupt passieren konnte. Und zwar offenbar über einen langen Zeitraum. Ja äh mindestens mehrere Jahre.
Erste Warnsignale schildert Viellet Blue vor zehn Jahren und ähm irgendwie ist es offenbar passiert, dass.
Sich in zehn Jahren des asozialen, regelmäßigen Fehlverhaltens.
Zu keinem bis jetzt äh nicht.
Eine Möglichkeit geboten hat, dem irgendwie Einhalt zu bieten. Das kann sein, dass es eben.
Dass das Verhalten krankhaft ist, wovon ich hier ernsthaft den Eindruck habe ähm das kann sein, dass.
Sich in keiner, in keinem Freundeskreis so lange aufgehalten hat, dass er da irgendwie über die Grenze gekommen ist. Ähm aber wir müssen es irgendwie klären, wie sowas über so lange Zeit gut geht.
Und am Ende offenbar nur das als Möglichkeit bleibt, was jetzt gerade passiert, dass nämlich seit wirklich jetzt über einer Woche äh diese Sau durchs Dorf getrieben wird mit,
katastrophalen ähm.
Gräben, die nun auch in diese Community von Communitys gerissen werden, ja? Dass du dich jetzt, dass du eben siehst, dass da jetzt Gruppen sind von.
Gruppen sind von.
Sage ich mal, die sich feministisch motiviert sehen ähm andere Gruppen, die sagen, na ja okay, pass mal auf, so, ich meine, ist okay,
Vorwürfe, aber wir müssen die schon in irgendeiner Form geprüft haben, bevor wir jetzt hier jemanden abschießen.
Und andere, die äh wahrscheinlich immer noch denken, dass das alles irgendwie der große Spinnes, den schon Julian Assange zum Opfer gefallen ist und so und ich sehe gerade mit großer Sorge, wie das einfach eskaliert.
Und sich wenig Gedanken,
wenig Gedanken gemacht wurden bisher über eben diesen Weg nach vorn, wie man so eine Machtausnutzung unterbinden kann, weil was die Person schildern ist und das halte ich für nachvollziehbar.
Dass hier sich nicht getraut haben, sich mit dem Typen anzulegen. Weil der zu viel Soziales Kapital hatte. Ne, der ist,
In einer gewissen Form weltbekannt, weil ich sagen muss, ich war ähm also ich habe mich ja jetzt leider,
oder vielleicht auch zum Glück sehr viel mit diesen Sachen auseinandersetzen müssen, hat mit vielen Leuten geredet und war jetzt eigentlich die ganze Zeit mit diesem mit diesem wunderbaren Thema beschäftigt und bin dann irgendwann mal mit so ein paar Nicht-Nerd-Freunden,
Sonntagnachmittag irgendwo und dann sagen die nur so eine Linus, du siehst ein bisschen fertig aus, hat womit beschäftigst du dich denn gerade? Dann sagt die Lose Jaycop, Apple Bound, die so hä? Ja
Das war ganz, das fand ich ganz schön. Ähm.
Ja, ja, das, das, das Feuer brennt in unserer Szene extrem und darüber hinaus äh so ein bisschen so ein schwarzes Loch, also hier stürzt gerade alles ein, aber so jenseits des Ereignis Horizonts äh merkt man davon irgendwie gar nichts.
Genau, wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwie überlegen, wir als die Community von Communitys müssen uns irgendwie überlegen, wie man mit so einer Sache umgeht. Äh da also jemand darf nicht, wir müssen verhindern, dass Leute in in eine Position kommen, wo sie so eine Macht,
Über andere ausüben können.
Beziehungsweise, wenn sie anfangen es zu tun entsprechende Rückmeldungs äh Systeme äh zu haben, die an der Stelle dann einfach
greifen, weil ich meine, dass hier jetzt jemand einen sozialen Aufstieg in einer Szene erlangt und und und populär wird durch durch die eigenen Taten oder Fähigkeiten, also weder halte ich das jetzt für per se verhinderbar, noch Verhinderungswürdig. Das hat ja auch was Gutes. Also es gibt ja einzelne
die sich einfach
durch eine gewisse Elloquenz oder durch eine gewisse äh Fähigkeit auch abstrakte schwerzugreifende Probleme sehr nachvollziehbar vermitteln zu können, auch einen gewissen Status ähm geschaffen haben. Das
zeichnet auch
äh im CSC-Umfeld einige aus, also da gibt es viele, viele gute Beispiele von Leuten, die das äh über die Jahre immer wieder äh so geleistet haben und daraus natürlich auch einen einen gewissen sozialen Status sich äh zwangsläufig damit erarbeitet haben. Das ist halt erstmal nichts falsches.
Falsch ist, dass wenn man diesen Status hat,
den ausnutzt, um Druck auf andere zu erzeugen und sie von Dingen abzuhalten oder zu Dingen sogar zu zwingen, bis hin zu solchen extremen Ausprägungen wie sexuellem,
äh Fehlverhalten. Das muss natürlich in irgendeiner Form sanktioniert werden, beziehungsweise überhaupt erstmal erkannt werden.
Und da brauchen wir.
Auf dieser Welt offenbar irgendwie eine Lösung für, dass man sagt, okay, wie wie kriegst du quasi ein Frühwarnsystem hin, dass du Angebote hast, wo du sagst, okay, es gibt Vertrauenspersonen, an die kannst du dich wenden?
Und die gehen solche Dinge an und zwar nicht in der Form, wie sie jetzt gerade stattfinden,
Ähm ich habe bin hier schon es zeichnet sich gerade das Bild, dass es wirklich.
Offenbar keine andere Möglichkeit mehr gab als diese Sachen öffentlich zu machen.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt nach diesen ganzen Entwicklungen.
Und es zeigt sich das Bild, dass er mehrere sehr eindeutige Verwarnungen bekommen hat.
Viele versucht haben mit ihnen zu sprechen und dass das, dass es da eben offenbar einfach diese Maßnahme nicht eine ist, mit der mit der leichtfertig in die Welt gegangen wurde.
Dennoch sind viele der Phänomene, die man jetzt gerade beobachtet natürlich wirklich ekelig. Also und ich möchte auch mir.
Ich möchte das getrennt betrachten. Ich kann nicht sagen.
Nur weil ich jetzt sage, dieses scheiß Graffiti ist eine Schweinerei, heißt das natürlich nicht, dass sie sagt, wie der, wie der Jack sich irgendwie verhalten hat, ist irgendwie top in Ordnung, steht steht total hinter. Und man muss dann natürlich diese diese Phänomene auch getrennt betrachten.
Und sehen, okay, was ist in dem, was hier.
Geschehen ist, wo wurde der Pfad, der äh der Erleuchtung verlassen, ja? Eben im Umgang mit dessen Verhalten über offenbar Jahre. Ähm es gibt da so Schilderungen und ich muss das.
Also ich finde ich ganz interessant. Ich habe das war so ein Artikel von einer äh Soziologin. Ich glaube noch nicht mal in dem Zusammenhang, die also so schrieb so, na ja.
Für so übergriffige Männer gibt's quasi so Codes. Das heißt, da da erzählst du als.
Frau oder Mann, die eine andere Person warnen wollen, also da ging's glaube ich eher um weibliche Codes in diesem Bereich. Erzählst du nicht unbedingt, der hat mich irgendwie, der ist mir zu nahe getreten oder so, sondern da sagt man dann so.
Ich würde aufpassen, wenn der trinkt.
Da weiß jeder weiß, da weiß man halt so, ah okay, ähm weiß Bescheid, ne? Und das das diese Kommunikation eben über Unterunterschwellige kurze.
Auch so eine Party würde ich nicht mitgehen.
Jetzt hast du es gesagt, also auf so eine Party würde ich nicht mitgehen, ähm da gab es viele Situationen, wo man das sagen konnte. Ähm schon früher bin ich auch nie. Hm, aber die ähm.
Sind Dinge, die jetzt auch sozusagen mir auch teilweise das allererste Mal überhaupt äh so in der Deutlichkeit näher gebracht wurden, dass eben solche Botschaften eben herumgereicht wurden, ne?
Erstaunlicherweise, wenn ich das noch kurz anmerken darf. Ich habe da also ich führe gerade viele Gespräche in dem Bereich, viele E-Mail-Austausch. Auch viele habe ich auch noch nicht geantwortet. Entschuldigte das. Ähm,
Wo du halt sowas geschildert kriegst, dass Personen, die jetzt wirklich nicht im Kernbereich.
Dieser Szene unterwegs sind und entsprechend mir eine sehr viel größere Nähe zu dieser Person zutrauen, als sie es selber,
hatten und die dann sagen so ja ich weiß davon seit Arnold Dunnemals erzähl mir doch bitte nicht, dass du davon nichts wüsstest, ne?
Ähm.
Sexuelles Fehlverhalten wusste ich tatsächlich nicht. Also das war dann irgendwie mehr als als äh das wirklich konkret wurde. Es also es gab immer ich meine, es war auch klar, ich meine dieser.
Der hat jetzt mit sein, dass er sexuell ist, das hat er glaube ich an keinem Tag seines Lebens irgendwie großartig verschwiegen, ganz im Gegenteil. Und es war schon immer irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Wo man irgendwie dachte so okay äh.
Was ist das jetzt, ne? Also war schon so ein bisschen, aber ähm es gibt eben einen Unterschied zwischen.
Spezielle vorzuvorlieben zu haben, ist ja äh kein Verbrechen und das äh muss auch äh Raum und Raum zur Ausprägung haben, solange es halt einfach unterfährt, Vorzeichen stattfindet.
Solange alle Beteiligten zu jedem Zeitpunkt mit allem, was passiert, einverstanden sind, ist,
alles erstmal okay. Und jetzt kommen eben die Fälle, wo das nicht der Fall war. Ähm,
Tja, also wir brauchen einen Weg nach vorne, wie wir das verhindern, dass Menschen,
so erstens solch ihre Machtposition ausnutzen, zweitens damit durchkommen.
Und drittens damit solange durchkommen bis wir irgendwie vor einem internationalen Scheiße Sprudel stehen ähm und einem gordischen Knoten, der jetzt,
das Potenzial hat diese Community ähm von Communitys richtig krass zu schädigen.
Und das ist ein Problem, das löst du nicht in ähm lest du nicht in wenigen Tagen, das löst du halt in in Monaten.
Es gibt eben die,
Selbstverständlichen Sofortmaßnahmen, äh die auch vom CC ergriffen wurden. Der ist selbstverständlich bei den Veranstaltungen des CCC und im CC nicht mehr willkommen.
Weiß das auch, hat auch ausrichten lassen, dass er.
Das zur Kenntnis geno.
Das nein, dass er auch gar nicht die Absicht hegt, äh sich da äh jemals oder sich da blicken zu lassen. Jemals ist da jetzt da jetzt dahin gestellt, ähm was.
Es gibt da ja auch diese Modelle, die eben von den betroffenen Personen hervorgebracht werden, die da durchaus einen Weg zur.
In irgendeiner Form.
Sage ich mal, Rehabilitation nicht unbedingt im Sinne der der Person in der Öffentlichkeit, aber des des Täters.
Aufzeichnen über all diese Dinge werden sich andere Leute zum Glück Gedanken machen müssen. Ähm,
Aber der Mann ist halt jetzt erstmal überall raus. Mein einziger Punkt ist, das ist halt nur die Grundvoraussetzung und Basis für das, was wir jetzt in Zukunft eben,
In dieser Community von Communitys und wahrscheinlich auch in unserer Gesellschaft angehen müssen,
Halte das für unwahrscheinlich, dass äh jetzt ausgerechnet er die einzige Person auf diesem Planeten ist, die jemals auf die Idee gekommen ist, eine Machtposition auszuüben und das dann auch noch äh äh in,
im sexuellen Bereich auf auf eine äh unschöne Weise,
Und da müssen wir uns irgendwie Gedanken drüber machen, dass wir, dass wir diese Phänomene nicht mehr haben. Und zwar die Gesamtheit der Phänomene, diese Öffentlichkeit, das Zerreißen.
Die Dauer mit der so etwas stattfinden kann.
Und dann natürlich auch ähm, dass man halt in der Lage ist, in solchen,
Das ist ein weiter Weg, aber ich hoffe, dass man irgendwann in Anbetracht derartiger Vorwürfe wirklich mal mit einer Besonnenheit.
Vorgehen kann. Und ich kann gleichzeitig sehr gut verstehen, dass 'ne ganze Menge Leute die mit dem Typen zu tun hatten über längere Zeit ihre Besonnenheit halt schon vor längerer Zeit abgelegt haben.
Absolut nachvollziehbar.
Ja, wie du schon sagst, ne? Also man muss halt jetzt überlegen, wie wie kann man das äh verhindern, dass es sich hätte ich jetzt keine keine Frage auf die eine einfache Antwort gibt,
Grundsätzlich.
Stelle ich fest, dass ähm zumindest in der Szene, die keinen Namen hat, diese Community auf Communitys, ja.
Ähm ähnliche Thematiken im zunehmendem Maße eine Rolle spielen. So, das der richtige Umgang miteinander.
Ist einfach ein Thema, ist etwas, was man auf dem Kongress äh sieht und was sich auch darüber hinaus äh in zunehmendem Maße Raum verschafft.
Zurecht und da spielt natürlich diese Geschichte jetzt auch mit rein und äh in gewisser Hinsicht können wir das halt natürlich auch als als Herausforderung sehen
an der Stelle eben auch einfach mal drüber nachzudenken, wie man das System verbessern kann. Das ist ja sagen wir mal auch ein gewisser sportlicher gewisses sportliche Herausforderung für so eine
äh Community. Und es ist eben auch auf vieles auch schon auch schon gute Antworten geliefert worden und ich habe ehrlich gesagt
bin da eigentlich ganz ganz guter Dinge, dass äh dass das auch gelingen kann.
Ich glaube, was wir jetzt wirklich, also was wir irgendwann hinkriegen müssen ist, wir brauchen halt so eine.
Befriedung und Versachlichung dieser Angelegenheit. Was ich bei Diskussionen um dieses Thema immer wieder beobachte, ist ähm.
Dass du, wie es im Internet, wie es im Internet üblich ist, eben den leisesten Hauch an Zweifel, an, an deiner eigenen Äußerung wahrnimmst, als eine Fundamentalkritik an allem, wofür du stehst, ja.
Genau. Oder einer Farhharmlerlosung der der Gegenposition.
Verharmlosung der Gegenposition. Ja, ist also auch dann irgendwie so, dann kriegst. Ne, also du darfst dieses Graffiti nicht kritisieren, weil das größere Problem ist das. Ne? Mit solchen ähm.
Mit solchen Perspektiven werden wir Problem,
Das unterliegende Problem nicht gelöst kriegen und das ist eigentlich das, was ich, was das, was das schockierende ist, ja? Das,
Konnte über so lange Zeit geschehen und es musste,
In einer Form eskalieren, die richtig, richtig unschön war für alle Beteiligten, für alle Beteiligten. Niemand sitzt da jetzt gerade und sagt, das ist aber schön, was hier gerade passiert. Es war richtig toll, da habe ich lange darauf gewartet,
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die wissen auch, dass ich sie gerade anspreche, aber sonst gibt's keinen. Ja? Und ähm das davon muss man sich schützen.
Alles gesagt erstmal, was.
Alles, was im Podcast dazu zu diesem Zeitpunkt gesagt werden kann,
wurde gesagt glaube ich hoffe ich wahrscheinlich vieles nicht. Ich hoffe, dass wir jetzt nicht irgendwie werden von irgendjemandem sowieso dafür Kritik kriegen, wie wir uns jetzt hier geäußert haben.
Sicherlich, aber unser Anliegen war einfach jetzt zunächst einmal den Fall einfach mal so auszurollen, wie er sich uns darstellt, wie er sich entwickelt hat, ähm
Wir haben natürlich wieder umfangreiche Links auf all die ganzen Beiträge, die wir hier erwähnt haben, sollte einer fehlen, ja, um Nachsicht und um Hinweis darauf, dann tragen wir das nach
und so dass man sich hier einfach auch mal selber ein Bild machen kann und auch sollte
Ja und an der Stelle.
Schließen wir das Kapitel jetzt vorerst, zumindest für diese Sendung erstmal ab.
Ja
Sendung.
Lange Sendung, ja. Lange Gesichter, lange Leben.
Ja, aber so ist es halt, ne? Da Versprechen mit kurzen Sendungen, das wird da eh nichts mehr. Aber in letzter Zeit gab's einfach auch eine ganze Menge zusammenzufegen. Termine gibt's heute nicht. Ähm,
Dinge stehen an, ansonsten ist vor allem.
Bald Sommer. Mit vielen lustigen äh Huckerveranstaltungen, die jetzt nicht äh.
Wollt haben, dass man auf sie hinweist, aber ich äh nehme.
Ab dem wartet doch nicht schon wieder. Nee, welche, welche denn?
Na ja,
aber die ich sozusagen jetzt hier wertvoll finde, äh dass man auf sie hinweist, also ich selber werde nach England fahren, auf das EMF äh Elektromagnetik fiel, so das englische äh Camp, was alle zwei Jahre stattfindet,
Anfang August. Dann habe ich mitbekommen, dass es äh daher eine ganze,
Woche, Hackerei, äh gibt auf der Insel Bornholm von.
Schwimmen oder Dänemark eigentlich? Dänemark, ne? Ähm von denen, denen denen,
einfällt, als ich äh eine Woche hakend auf einer Insel zu setzen.
Und äh dann gibt es auch noch später im August, äh was jetzt gerade das Datum nicht auch noch eine entsprechende Camp-Aktivität in Ungarn.
Also es ist eine Menge los und wer sich sozusagen der der Idee des Camps äh mal in anderer Form und vor allem an anderen Orten
anschließen will und äh die Europäisierung der Netzszene voranbringen möchte, äh ist da sicherlich ganz gut aufgehoben.
Bei den Veranstaltungen.
Ja, das wird bestimmt eine Freude.
Und jetzt sagen wir tschüss, wa?
Ich muss noch kurz danke sagen,
Ich suche das noch schnell zusammen. Warte mal, ich habe nämlich eine Sache vergessen, wo habe ich die denn liegen? Also der Dank in dieser Woche gilt äh Sebastian Stefan Krostia und.
Einer weiteren.
Alexander.
Personen.
Genau und und tatsächlich noch eine weitere Person, von der ich nur die äh E-Mail-Adresse habe, deswegen schreibe ich da einfach persönlich nochmal kurz was hin.
Und wie immer natürlich auch allen anderen Unterstützern, Spendern und wohlwollenden Tippgebern und Korrigierern und Hörern und.
Und ich möchte noch Anna danken. Ich möchte noch Anna danken für die Sendung letzte Woche, die war nämlich spitze. Muss ich echt sagen, ja, fand ich super. Hat mir echt super gefallen, war ich sehr beeindruck.
Schön zu wissen, dass ich dann irgendwann wenn ich dann auf die einsame Insel abhaue.
Das hat trotzdem nur eine brauchbare Sendung bei raus.
Lasst das auch ohne mich funktioniert, wenn nicht wenn ich das mit diesem scheiß Internet irgendwann endlich sein lasse.
Die Lücken äh kriege ich gefüllt. So, wir sagen tschüss. Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.
Ciao ciao.